okay so uh uh now we're for sure this
time Donald Trump has actually said he
will generously offer up his time and
energy to serve as interim speaker of
the house to help unify the Republicans
said he'll be the great unifier that's
what he's going to do and I am just
begging all of you please I implore you
I'm looking into the eyes of every
Republican member of Congress right now
do what you know must be done nominate
second and vote for Donald Trump as
Speaker of the House give the people
what they want now I gota be honest I
actually think there's a strong
possibility it could happen right now I
mean strong doesn't mean greater than
majority doesn't mean 90% but I'm also
wondering because nobody really wants to
do it there's a handful I mean scalise
wants to do it Jim Jordan wants to do it
they'll probably go in that direction
but there is perhaps at least a single
digit or double- digit percentage chance
that if Donald Trump gets the nomination
many Republicans will be concerned that
if they don't support him it could be
bad for them considering Donald Trump is
polling so well right now there's a huge
opportunity to signal to your base and
your District like hey look man I'm
backing Donald Trump too I'm just like
you guys and I I hope and I pray that's
the case so we'll talk about that plus
we got a bunch of other news Putin's
threatening to Nuke and wipe out the
West okay I guess here we go again and
uh then we have Elon Musk is being sued
by the
before we get started with all that my
friends head head over to
timcast.net to be on stage we've got a
pre-show we've got an after show we've
got Alex Stein it is going to be amazing
we've got bags of free stuff for all of
you who attend and uh I am I it is just
you know you we've planned this event
for a long time now it's been like a
year in the making and uh we booked met
Gates a while ago but with all the work
that he's done you know I've got people
coming coming up to me be like wow great
timing like you know it's really awesome
that you got Matt Gates and I'm like
dude we booked Matt Gates well before he
was doing you know this fight in
Congress so we're really really honored
to have him and of course originally Don
Jr was going to come he couldn't make it
but James o'keef stepped up Patrick B
DAV will be there this is going to be
absolutely amazing tickets are going
fast but we do we do have tickets
available and our Elite members there
will be a meet up tomorrow for all of
you we're at 3 pm. it's going to be
absolutely amazing so head over to
timcast.net
and bring them on down it's going to be
amazing I'm really excited to hear uh
Matt Gates talk about the fight in
Congress right now and the work that
he's doing but also don't forget to
click join us become a member so you can
participate in our Discord Community
which is it's basically an app you can
download for those not familiar and it's
a chat room multiple chat rooms you hang
out with people who are like-minded or
sometimes not maybe you argue but
they're working on culture they're
making music there's pre-shows after
shows all within the Discord community
and as a member you get access to our
uncensored members only show which will
be up tonight at about 10: p.m. and once
you're in the Discord server you can
submit questions call in and talk to us
it's going to be a blast so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share this show with your friends
joining us tonight we got a couple of
guests we've got Michael Cipher how's it
going everybody Michael Cipher founder
and CEO of Public Square largest
non-woke Marketplace in the world over
70,000 businesses that don't hate you
and love the country and they love the
Constitution I'm a huge fan of the
Public Square app as most of you know
and we that's why we shout it out so
much because people keep saying like
what can we do to win and the by cots
have been tremendously successful in
forcing companies to back off from
wokeness now I don't think Vanguard and
black rock and all of them actually are
getting away from it but they're
certainly saying it why I don't know
when Bud Light Lost 30 m $30 billion
that matters a lot so Public Square you
download it you sign up and you can see
a map of all of these businesses in your
area that share your values really
really great stuff so I'm obviously a
huge fan thanks for joining it's going
to be a blast we got Alex britz as well
up glad to be back thanks for having me
Tim and uh I'm Alex brtz I'm a prot
trump political consultant work with
most of the the great people in the
magga world that you're big fans of
probably and uh love coming on timcast
always right on man thanks for thanks
for hanging out of course Luc is here
hey guys my name is Zukowski of
youtube.com wear change and today I'm
wearing a very perfect shirt for uh
parties or for incel incels it has three
boxes one of them says single another
one of them says taken the third one
that is checked says resisting the blank
blank corporatist banking cabal with
memes and thought crimes to see what is
underneath this piece of tape and what
this shirt really says go check out
thepolitical shirts.com and I want to
thank Public Square for doing what
they're doing I have my uh supplement
and health bu business up there on we
are change. shop so thank you guys for
doing everything you're doing and this
should be a great conversation thank you
glad to be here right on we got search
pressing the
buttons yo yeah I'm over here just
trying to keep myself muted so it sounds
good of course of course I also
mentioned tomorrow's event is sponsored
by Public Square you guys have helped us
put this event on so I'm I'm really
grateful for that but we're also very
excited we've got bags with products
from Public Square companies to give out
to everybody who comes it's going to be
awesome let's jump into the news ladies
and gentlemen we got this one from The
Daily Beast and I chose The Daily Beast
on purpose because we love how leftist
they are
Donald Trump says he's open to being
house speaker for a short period oh how
generous and this is what they wrote
they wrote Donald Trump says he's
generously offered up his services to be
an interim speaker of the house until
GOP brass can sort out which Republican
it wants in Congressional leadership for
the long term Trump told Fox News that
he's been approached by lawmakers and
was queried about his interest in the
position which he's technically eligible
to hold despite not being a member of
Congress I have been asked to speak as a
unifier because I have so many friends
in Congress Trump said if they don't get
the vote they have asked me if I would
consider taking the speakership the
ex-president made clear that becoming
house Speaker would not deter from his
plans to retake the White House in next
year's presidential election other names
that have been floated uh as potential
house speaker to replace Kevin McCarthy
is Jim Jordan Tom emmer and Steve scales
I think it's got to be Trump it's got to
be Trump for one simple reason he would
unify it would it would end the fighting
no one is going to want to be the person
who said I told Donald Trump currently
the most popular man running for
president the front runner I told him no
and obstructed if Trump comes in first
of all I don't think he just goes and
insults one side or the other side or or
this group or that group or this person
he actually says here's what we're going
to get done here's here's what we going
to make happen and whether it be Matt
Gates or anyone else they're going to be
like I'm going to defer to Donald Trump
yeah I think from a numbers perspective
you have to get the 218 votes and
looking at some of these other names on
the list Jim Jordan I think he's also so
probably a front runner of trump is not
interested uh but Steve scales and Tom
emmer they're both going to have
tremendous trouble getting to 218
president Trump comes in he's already
have like he already has like 110
Congressional endorsements for his
presidential Bid And You Know Dan santis
is the second closest with four and so
you know president Trump is the most
popular Republican in the party and in
Congress right now in Congress I mean
and not even as a member of Congress but
considering he's the front runner I'm
wondering what would happen considering
he said he'll do it that he's been asked
to do it he's been nominated this time
it's more serious than the first time I
remember when uh Matt Gates nominated
Trump first time around and it was seen
as kind of silly because Trump wasn't
going to do it now that Trump said yes
imagine being that one rank and file
Republican who has to tell your District
you voted against Donald Trump as
Speaker of the House yeah well he's
already pulling about 60% there's no way
yeah why why did you uh not support
Trump and go for some
Rhino nope no I'm just you know look
maybe I'm just saying this because I
really want it to happen but I really
want it to happen yeah it would be
hilarious I so badly want yeah Trump's
not really known as a unifier from uh
everything I I've garnered over the last
few years but this would be the most
interesting outcome um and I think he
does want it he wouldn't be saying what
he's saying right now if he didn't want
the position so um you know what let's
do it I I I want I want to see this I
want to see him there I want to see him
in Congress I mean this would also kind
of derail his presidential run because
he wouldn't be able to be in key States
like New Hampshire he wouldn't be able
to be in Iowa he wouldn't be able to be
uh in places like Michigan as well where
he needs to be you're under the you're
under the assumption that Congress works
it doesn't it doesn't work I mean when
Nancy Pelosi was speaker they worked a
100 days out of the year and Kevin
McCarthy had a little bit more of a
strict schedule with this Congress but I
mean you have you're on for four days
and you're off for 12 there a bunch of
lazy welfare queens and on top of that
he'd have nonstop media coverage every
camera every day I mean imagine like
he's already has basically non-stop
media coverage but this is just even
more this would not derail his campaign
this would launch it to the moon imagine
he does one little thing right we saw
Patrick McKenry boots Nancy Pelosi from
her office and it's Front Page News a
big deal Nancy Pelos is like how is
breaking tradition and it's hilarious
imagine if Trump orders the floor to be
mopped and then they're like Donald
Trump is now ordering janitors around
it's Front Page News it would give him
for for for the entire duration of
however long he does it and it would be
worth billions of dollars well and he
could pull the whole like my competitors
in the primary are out just fundraising
and they're out and I'm working for the
American people that's a powerful
message I I yeah I'm I'm a fan of this
I'm a fan of it purely because it's so
entertaining well just looking at the
other options I mean I think Jim
Jordan's the best of the other the other
options but you know Steve scalise was
considering a run against McCarthy
during January that
wasn't reported a ton but there was some
reports out there uh Steve wanted that
speakership he was whipping people
behind the scenes saying if Kevin can't
make it I want to be that guy but I
think Steve would have been worse than
Kevin you know I sat across from Steve
in a donor's house and paulm beach uh in
uh I want to say September of 22 two
months before the midterms and I asked
Steve why were you raising money for
candidates that impeach Donald Trump why
were you working again Mega canids
running against you know some of these
these rhinos and he's like well I I'll
need to take a look at that I didn't
know that we were raising money for
these people I'm like how don't you know
that you're raising money for these
people you were literally there at a
fundraiser for them oh I'll have to take
a look I don't remember that and so you
know he came down to Palm Beach for a
big check he thought he was the man and
then the donor called me and said come
on over so I came on over sat across
from Steve and grilled him for an hour
and he left with uh like a third of the
money he came for he was pissed so he
doesn't like me a whole lot but then you
have Tom emmer who's another guy that is
not aligned with the voter base he's not
aligned with the Trump Republican party
which makes up 75% of Congress if not
more and you know he was telling donors
not to donate to Trump in 2024 uh
allegedly he was also going uh on CNN
before the midterms telling candidates
his advice to them is don't say Trump's
name when you're campaigning meanwhile
he's sending out dozens of fundraising
emails saying this is Donald Trump and
we need you to donate to the n our CC
and so you have these people with a lot
of baggage and again you have to get to
218 and so if you're doing math you're
not going to get to 218 if you're some
of these other guys and you have all
these people working against you so so
some people are asking in the Super Chat
they heard that Donald Trump can't be
speaker because he's under indictment
and that's not allowed but that's just a
GOP rule that they could literally just
be like okay we don't care anymore it
really just comes down to the
Republicans being like yeah we don't
care we want Trump what do you guys
think but real quick real quick sorry
sorry it could give an excuse to a
republican when he votes against Trump
as speaker and his constituents or or
her constituents say why didn't you
support Trump and he says the GOP rule
we had a rule that says you can't be and
and they're trying to break the rule and
I just think that's wrong and that
that'll be the route let's say uh uh
Trump becomes speaker what is going to
be his first
move impeach Joe Biden I mean honestly
yeah he might want to bring it to the
floor he's also got to fully cut any
funding for Ukraine and make that the
hill because you know that that was the
big thing that everybody's pissed off
about I think investigating Hunter Biden
be would be a very important aspect he
also demanded that Europe Finance this
Ukrainian War and the United States pay
less uh for this conflict as well so um
yeah Congress does have purchasing
Powers so if he becomes speaker and then
brings like Marjorie Taylor Green's
Biden impeachment to the floor and then
Biden gets impeached and now what what's
the current balance of power in the
Senate we've got got Feinstein is out
it's very close it's very close
Feinstein is out and then um so I I so
where where does that put them right now
and you've got man men Menendez is on
the ropes yeah they're not going to kick
him out because he need the vote I know
I know but but where are they currently
is it still a tie I think it's a tie
even with Feinstein out no they
disappointed no she just got replaced by
black lesbian a black lesbian from
Marland Maryland the woman lived in
Maryland according to you you know what
was really interesting is that I think
it was Mike serich pointed this out that
Adam Schiff wanted to run yeah and now
he's basically been spiked because of
this but but my point is if Donald Trump
gets Kamala and uh Biden both impeached
as Speaker of the House he's president
well you have to go to the Senate and I
mean we don't we don't have friend but
that's why I was asking about like
what's the balance currently at you know
yeah but you're right you're right I
mean we the Biden has more friends in
the Senate on the Republican side than
Trump does I mean I think our Senate's a
disaster I mean we are so frustrated
with the house and I think it's easy to
blame the house and you know McCarthy
you know did get a lot of the Heat and
the blame but the Senate is impossible
to work with on these issues you have
Republican Senators going on field trips
to Ukraine just as often as the
Democrats are and I real quick I just
need to point out too in order to
convict an impeachment you need what
like 63 or something 65 I think you need
Super majority yeah it's not it's not
just 50 51 and you got Lindsey Graham in
there Mitt Romney and all these horrible
rhinos and politicians that don't give a
damn about anybody right and Lady G also
known as Lindsey Graham but you know
right before election Lindsay was like
Joe Biden's one of the kindest people
I've ever met in my life I'm like these
people make me sick and so you know we
have like 10 good Senators uh if you're
a republican you have 10 good senators
and that's it and so we have a long way
to go up there uh Carrie lakes's running
for the Senate again so we'll see what
happens in Arizona but again for the
first time for the first time rather yes
but so that's official right she she she
did Tuesday's the the lunch but we'll
see what happens but yeah I S it's a
disgrace but I think Trump for speaker
is what the what the people want and
what the people need and I I I hope like
his first move is just to like annoy and
and agitate you know like we we saw
Nancy Pelosi get evicted and it was
hilarious and I'm like you know I got to
be honest if the only thing we get out
of Matt Gates's efforts and these other
Republicans then uh is Nancy Pelosi
getting evicted I'm I'm happy with that
right because uh
uh with with Kevin McCarthy in you might
as well have a Democrat majority funding
for Ukraine you name it Democrat IES are
getting what they want it's remarkable
to me that the Republican majority says
we actually are scrutinizing Ukrainian
funding and the Democratic party says
we're for it so Kevin McCarthy goes I'm
going to go with Democrats on this one I
mean that what was the point of winning
in 2022 what was the point of all the
efforts so he's got to go and then if
Donald Trump comes in I don't see him I
gotta be honest I do see Trump
negotiating with democrats for sure he's
going to be more moderate Than People
expect Trump will probably be a bit more
moderate I shouldn't say moderate Trump
will be a bit more favorable to the EST
establishment than Matt Gates would be
but Trump would be substantially better
than I I guess anyone else you could get
well and the people want him I think
well and in the Senate you've got Mitch
McConnell who believes last week as he
said that the number one priority of
Republicans is to support the war effort
in Ukraine and it's like you can't be
more out of touch with the base than
that and so if he comes in and has a few
key issues that he drives forward if he
talks about immigration I mean even the
Democrats are waking up to how awful
illegal immigration is in their cities
and so it's like if he made some of
these issues kind of key focal points if
he brought up pictures of the evidence
from Hunter Biden on stage and like
called out the Sham that this is that he
only got a slap on the wrist for a
filing issue with a firearm like he he
would immediately have traction with uh
I think a lot of people in the house
that would say he's legit this is cool
you know I've worked with a lot of the
Congress members and I've worked with
them before they they got into Congress
and they they run they have all these
ideas and they have all this excitement
they want to make all of this change and
then they get there and they introduce
something and it has to sit it sits
there until it gets through a committee
and then you know the committee might
not even bring and so they didn't
realize how slow of a process this
really was like Congress is a broken
institution and uh you can go in with
great intentions but it's so easy to
fall into the you know the the swamp
this this is what I don't get like does
someone have dirt on bobert margerie and
and Thomas Massie right cuz like they're
they're Thro to defense of Kevin
McCarthy and Thomas Massie going so far
to say like yelling that if if they if
we remove him this institution will fail
and I'm just like bro no one in this
country likes your institution are you
so removed from what this is that you
can't you can't see that that the
American people would rather watch
Congress we we mentioned this the other
day if you go to any single American 82%
of the time you ask them would you
rather we replace all members of
congress with golden retrievers or leave
it the way it is gold retriever
absolutely obstruction of doofy dogs
running around playing is better than
what we got yeah well boer's in a in a
very difficult District so bobert won
her election by like 200 votes this last
time and not only does she have the
Democrat Party working against her she
has a ton of Republicans spending big
money against her and so I'm not saying
that she she sided with Kevin McCarthy
but what she's trying to do is she's
trying to keep that seat and I think her
seat's important to keep because our map
is super small we just lost a district
in Alabama because of redistricting and
if you look across the country we're
never going to have this 30 seat
majority again for the next few decades
like we have a super small majorities
either way just because of the way the
math is and and if that's the case and
the fear is if I stand against Kevin
McCarthy I will not get the funding to
win the way you solve this problem is by
all of these people standing up to Kevin
McCarthy tell him he is no longer
welcome and these deals that he cuts
behind the scenes don't play won't play
anymore but if if you get people like
Marjorie Taylor green she I get it she
wants her committee assignments she was
booted off last time around and so she's
trying to be more I guess I guess she's
trying to to play ball to a certain
degree I don't mean disrespectfully I
mean she's she's trying to like get what
she can she get get what she can uh get
done done but all that does is Kick the
Can down the road and perpetuate the
problems I think what Matt Gates is
doing is the right move and I think
these problemss get solved overnight if
all of these people who are at risk go
to Kevin and say you know what fine do
it pull the funding don't support us I
literally don't care anymore let them
have it call their Bluff well that's
what's weird that the criticism of gates
was that this will cause chaos I'm like
why prefer Chaos versus destruction of
our life exactly like if the options are
an institution being irreparably broken
screwing me over or chaos I'm going to
choose chaos plus regardless of how you
feel about the matter Matt Gates's
speech to the reporters that night on
the capital steps when he was sharing
basically a three-minute spiel about why
he did what he did like you can't really
disagree with any of his words Americans
don't feel heard they don't feel
represented by these people we elect
them they go off they use our money
against us and the uni party has become
a very clear established thing and it no
longer serves the interest of the
American people so he has every right to
kind of lay the foot down I want to pull
up this uh I got this tweet from Matt
Gates he said okay let's negotiate my
GOP colleagues want to raise the
threshold on the motion to vacate okay
let me pause right there for right now
it takes a single person to file this is
something that Matt got negotiated the
first time around a single person can
file and then they have to vote right
now the argument is they should raise
the threshold and make it harder so Matt
says this is a question for all of them
the GOP if we enact the reforms rep Rana
lays out here how high would you like
the motion to vacate threshold to be cuz
I'll basically give you whatever you
want on the motion to vacate for this
stuff and what is he saying a ban on
Congressional stock trading 12year term
limit for Congress and a ban on
political donations from lobbyists or
packs here here Matt Gates mhm and this
is a Democrat this is a bipartisan
effort yeah c can they wear the
corporate logos that also Finance them
and support them on their suits that's a
great idea I think that would be also a
very fair and now if you're concerned as
a member of Congress that you need the
money and the backing from the machine
here's a way you can you can go out with
a bang if if you if you think you're not
coming back work with Matt Gates on
getting rep r reforms anti-corruption
plan and fundamentally change the game
you know what I think happens though
this happens to
everybody name name an individual who's
idealistic and says when I get in I'm
going to fix this stuff and what happens
Donald Trump said he was going to arrest
Hillary Clinton he didn't do that why
everyone gets in and then says one I
have to prioritize do I want to build a
wall secure the Border or spend my time
chasing after Hillary Clinton and that's
why she falls to the back we're not
going to do it we're we're not going to
go for it people get into Congress and
they're like I am going to fight this
machine and then what
happens they jump into the river for the
first time they're they're watching the
flow and they say I'm going to jump in
there I'm going to push back and then
eventually the river sweeps them up
they're sitting there thinking like what
can I get done in these broken
institutions because if you if you
resist you get swept up you go off the
water you go off the cliff the waterfall
but if you play ball maybe you can get a
little bit more money for your District
maybe you can bring about a little
social change right here or there but
the big changes they don't they don't
get now in my view I think you're better
off just standing your ground holding
your own and if everyone who said I'm
going to get in and make a change did
they'd be changed overnight M the
problem is people go in and now we're
looking at Marjorie Taylor green
supporting The Establishment candidate
who is working with Democrats in secret
Lauren bobbert doing the same thing and
I get it is Lauren bobbert capable of
doing anything if she gets ousted in the
in the in the next in next next year no
of course not so she needs as much
support as she can get so she's building
allies but then what do we get the same
broken corrupt institution the American
people despise over and over and over
again until someone says yo I don't care
to be part of a broken institution I
will stand against it to try and fix it
like like Matt is doing actually until
we get more people joining in it's just
the American people are going to keep
spitting on and laughing at and mocking
Congress yeah I think I mean the term
limits thing would solve a lot of the
problems I think the that would solve a
even a lot of the financial problems uh
because a freshman member comes in they
typically don't get the best committee
assignments and but a lot of the
lobbyists and the big the special
interest groups they see who has the
potential to climb the ranks and
eventually get the chairmanship or a
ranking member uh position on these
committies and once you that's when you
have the real power that's when you
decide where the money's going that's
when you decide who's getting the
contracts and so um you know if you're
only in there for 12 years like you know
you you don't really have the time to
play that that game and I think that
would make the committee members become
not just like right now it's like a
seniority thing if you're there for x
amount of years and and you are on this
committee then you deserve the
chairmanship and you need to break that
mode you have to have the most competent
and capable people in that role people
that can't get bought I think one of the
best things of this current Congress is
having a guy named Jason Smith on the
Ways and Means Committee he's the one
that's un you know surfacing all of the
IRS whistleblower stuff he's he's a guy
you never hear from you probably always
hear about Jim Jordan and J James comr
but you never hear Jason Smith Jason
Smith's the one that's producing results
but he's not sending out fundraising
emails saying hey support me and so um
Jason Smith was not supposed to be the
chairman of the Ways and Means Committee
senority would have had a got in ver
Buchanan do that but I'll give credit
where credit is due Kevin McCarthy put
Jason Smith on that committee and he
said he's that guy and so um you need
competent and capable people that can't
be bought Jason's one of those guys we
need more like Jason
Trump just put Trump as Speaker guys if
you're in Congress you're a Republican
and you're like this is insane
everybody's fighting just vote Trump
have you ever heard one good argument
against any of these points like why
well term limits yes what's the argument
against term limits you get someone as
good as Ron Paul you don't want him to
leave you want him to hold his ground
and do his best but Ron Paul was also
fighting for term limits yeah cuz isn't
that where the sort of Washington
attitude comes in of like hey I know you
want me but I'm out I'm going back to my
farm I'm going to that's what power was
supposed to be it was supposed to be
people that have built businesses or
served their communities they go in they
work in Congress for a bit and then they
depart they keep going with their lives
like that was what it was supposed to be
the idea is with uh with with term
limits you will have Shadow
organizations that are propping up their
their next crop of candidates and
they're they'll be cultivating them
years in advance and then they're going
to control the political Front Runners
and they and they do they do this they
they do they're you know they they will
get press attention for their young
person they want to run eventually
and the idea with term limits is it
would actually the the the rare time you
get someone good who's very popular and
loved by the community they have to go
and now you're starting from scratch
meanwhile you're up against a massive
machine that's cranking and churning out
these NPC like K it's I'm not saying I
actually disagree with ter I'm I'm I'm
actually for it for the most part
because the the ban on political
donations from lobbyist and PS I think
actually solves a lot of those issues
when you were describing that for some
reason I was thinking about AOC but uh
that's beyond the point I'm still very
bullish on this NASCAR suit idea which I
think would solve a lot of problems so
the American people would know uh
whatever Corporation is financing and
sponsoring these people but I don't
think there's anything solving this
problem if we look at this problem it's
been consistent it's it's been going on
for a very long time I still remember
when uh we were making videos there was
a new study that came out and this was
uh when we were talking many many years
ago uh specifically looking at the wants
interest and needs of the American
people that never get met in Congress
special interest groups do get met it's
a big Occupy Wall Street talking point
exactly and and it's and it's an honest
it's a real talking point when you look
at the data when you look at the
people's wants and needs and you look at
what Congress is doing it's usually the
exact opposite of that as of course
they're for the wars they're for uh the
medical intervention in our lives
they're for extra regulations extra
rules that prevent people from competing
with the billionaire class that of
course they support fully so so I don't
think there's any fixing this problem I
think that there's there's people who
are going to walk away from this problem
and I think that's going to be the
biggest solution out of all of this in
my opinion I think one thing that Trump
doesn't get enough credit for is his
5-year lobbying ban on federal officials
so you can't go from a federal office
job to lobbying like you used to and so
that he got that done the new thing now
is TV contracts so there's a story about
Ken Buck who was actually one of the
guys that voted to remove McCarthy but
he did so because he felt like McCarthy
was too aggressive against Hunter Biden
and so you know Ken Buck said I'm not
going to vote for this impeachment and
then he walked it back but then there
was a story that came out that said Ken
Buck was in negotiations with CNN to get
a contract and leave Congress and so you
know if you look at like Jason chaitz
from Utah he left Congress got Fox News
contract Trey gy left Congress got Fox
News contract booster seed Adam kininger
left Congress got CNN contract and so
because you have this lobbying ban now
the corporate press is just going up and
buying these people's opinions and
having them go you know not Lobby but
message and so you know we have to
figure out we have to stop Congress and
these federal jobs from being Stepping
Stones to more lucrative careers I I I
think there's a very simple solution uh
as to how we implement the solution to
be determined but the general IDE is you
get uh uh term limits right if you're
president you get two terms if you're
member of the Senate you get two terms
if you're members of Congress I think
you'll get six 12 years and then after
this you are sent to Mars we put you on
a spaceship and you help go colonize
Mars where you will no longer have any
influence Power Authority on Earth uh I
know maybe the Mars things a little
extreme because we don't know where Elon
Musk is currently with Starship but the
other idea is we just buil an island
called like former politician Island and
the idea is if you really want to be a
politician you know you are sacrificing
your standing in the community and once
you're done you will not be a part of it
well those politicians really do love
their Islands okay they love to go on
them a lot and do uh
but you see here's the point you can
also trick the bad ones be like hey
remember those islands you're going to
love it and then they go to the penal
colony where they're you know living in
Jump they've jumpsuits in their little
uh Studio I was literally thinking about
the idea as you were saying it but these
these politicians they they believe that
they're still entitled to all their
rights as a private citizen when they go
and represent us and they forget that
they work for us that was ny's whole
argument against the Congressional stock
trading and she said I'm a you know I'm
a I'm a free American we should be able
to trade stocks as a free American it's
like you don't understand that when you
go and actually represent us you're
willing to give up some of your
day-to-day yep things because you work
for me now like that's what you're
acknowledging so no you actually don't
get to trade stocks like a free citizen
because you have access that I don't
have imagine you hire someone you let's
say you have an ice cream shop and you
hire a young person you're like I need
you to you know you're going to work 9:
to 5 and you're going to serve ice cream
to the people and they go you got it and
then one day you come in it's 3:00 p.m.
and they're gone and you're like I'm
paying this person where are they and
then they come back the next day and
they're like I a free person this is
America I'm allowed to go to the park I
mean people are allowed to go to the
park and you're like yeah but not on my
dime if you don't want to work here
you're fired if AO like there are there
are many many jobs where you are no
longer eligible for things right
whenever you see uh uh like a sweep
Stakes or something you must like when
you felt the form or whatever it's like
I confirm my family or I are not
employees of said company or whatever
well that's not fair I'm an American I
should be able to enter the sweep Stakes
even though I work for the company no
when you're in Congress it's a conflict
of interest to bring bills to the floor
and vote on them when you are buying
stocks or trading on these things yeah
so no that should be absolutely banned
and I'm surprised well I'm not surprised
I'm not surprised it's legal but I'm
just I it's something that literally
should be banned absolutely and a lot of
Republicans are the worst offenders I
think unusual Wales is one of my
favorite Twitter accounts to follow
always exping because you know I learned
so much about the Republican Congress
members I had no clue and you know
there's this guy out of Georgia
Republican member who's like the best
stock Trader in the world um and so you
know we we need to put a stop to this I
think there is populist bipartisan
support uh on this and I'd like to see a
bill actually hit the floor um but I'm
glad to see that Rana and Matt Gates can
you know team up on this we'll see what
happens uh but it it does need to happen
yeah yeah it's almost as if both parties
are corrupt and they're kind of working
together in some kind of uni party way
screwing over and skinning the American
is that yeah I think we just did yeah
well so I'm the CEO of a public company
and when and and chairman and so on our
board if you want to be a director or an
officer of a public company you have all
these restrictions around how you trade
stock even you have to issue all the
stocks that you've traded in other
people's companies it's an lengthy
document and everything you do is
scrutinized and documented you have
blackout periods like it's very simple
to Institute a blackout period for
congressmen and women because it's very
simple like you have access I have
access as the CEO of the company that
the public doesn't have therefore I
should not be able to trade in the same
times that other people do this is not a
a difficult concept and if anybody is
actually objecting to it it's purely
because they have bad intentions there's
not a good reason as a sitting member of
Congress to say yeah you know what we
deserve the same rights to trade as
other people even while I know what's
going to happen with the electric
vehicle Bill three weeks before anybody
else like that's just not fair yeah it's
instead of trading it is plain and
simple yeah what what what did they go
after Martha Stewart for I mean whatever
it is she did I don't even know it's
been a long time but uh it's
substantially worse to be directly
interfering you know I'll tell you I'll
tell you uh out here in Florida they
have this interesting thing with their
their casinos and California does this
as well where you don't play you don't
bet against the house so if you if
you're in California you're playing
Blackjack there's a blackjack dealer you
and then the designated player the
designated player is a company that
bankrolls when you bankrolls your
winnings and and takes your takes takes
the money from you the reason they have
this is the idea the idea in these
States California and Florida do this
and it's not it's not totally Florida
there's like seminal that they're uh an
Indian a Native American reservation so
they do whatever they want but the idea
is if you're running the game and
betting against people you're cheating
yeah that's right it's like if I'm like
hey you want to bet against me I make
the rules and I'm going to determine how
the game is played it's like yeah you're
getting scammed in the NFL a wide
receiver for the Atlanta Falcons bet on
himself and his own success and got
suspended for an entire
season so like he said I'm going to be
great this game and he gets like a th
bucks it'd be one thing if he said I'm
going to lose and then he spiked the
game right but if he's like I'm the best
I'm going to win and then he wins like
no you can't do that this is literally
what they're doing in Congress they they
know a bill is being introduced that
it's it's like the ban electric cars
bill then they buy short they they short
electric car stock introduce the bill
and say we're now going to vote on
Banning electric cars oh it might happen
stock dips they make a profit and go n
we're kicking it back it's not going to
happen yeah then the stock spikes we
can't let this continue and um I think
we are getting a congress at least the
house that is becoming more aligned with
the people a lot closer to the people
than the Senate is but um you know more
we need more Matt Gates's in Congress to
get that done let's uh let's talk about
this story from the post millennial
reporters confront White House Press
Secretary after Biden announces border
wall breaking campaign promise I love
this cuz apparently Joe Biden is
claiming the wall doesn't work and he
has no choice but but to build it and
then you had uh who was it was it uh um
was it blinkin so uh someone in the
Biden admin came out and now they're
like well we got to have a wall I'll
tell you what you're seeing right here
with the story Joe Biden is violating
Federal what it he broke 24 26 laws or
something like that 26 federal laws in
South Texas to allow the border wall
construction now I gotta say like based
Joe Biden here here here's what happens
all these Democrats are crying their
eyeballs out and now Joe Biden has no
choice but to act this is the kind of
thing that spikes them in 2024 you the
the Republicans are going to play every
video of every Democrat saying let them
come bring open the borders and then we
got to close the borders oh gez and
they're going to say don't vote for
people who are too stupid to realize
that opening the Border causes problems
yeah Trump wanted 5 billion to build the
wall New York just spent 10 billion to
house migrants like and this stuff is so
aggravating because the media will never
tell the truth about this remember the
kids in cages and all these things like
Trump was the Tyrant at the border this
dude now recognizes the you know pile
that he's laying in here and he's trying
to make the wise decision finally and
the media will never report it he's
still the compassionate one I feel bad
for uh uh Jean Pierre because she's not
really good at this job dude and it's a
really difficult moment to have the the
president flip-flop so heavily how do
you answer that question like even a
seasoned you know press person is going
to be like this is going to be a
challenge we're going to have to figure
out a good answer for this one because
anybody with eyes is going to be like as
soon as Democrats got mad you guys
turned around and flipped on this she
has no good answer I mean Trump built
almost 500 miles of wall with just
incredible push back the Democrats did
everything they possibly could to stunt
this wall like from being built and he
still got 500 Miles built one of my
favorite stories about how the Democrats
tried stopping the wall was they funded
this uh butterfly migration organization
that sued the Trump administration
because they couldn't let Mexican
butterflies fly into the country and
they successfully halted the wall for
like 7even months eight months and it
went all the way up to you know some
some federal court until they ended up
losing but they used the butterflies to
stop Trump from building the wall for a
while
yeah really pisses me off what's
interesting is I'm from San Diego the
wall works amazingly there it has
transformed the city you know San Diego
is one of the hubs one of the most
primary hubs in the world for sex
trafficking and uh it's sad what happens
in San Diego uh the wall has been a
major deterrent of all of that like it's
it's fortified it is actually secure and
what it does too is it forces a lot of
migrants they're still going to try to
come into San Diego they go via water
but the waterways in San Diego if you've
ever been massive Cliffs it's very hard
to get access to the land so they've
created this really impenetrable system
and you know who's most grateful for it
when I was in San Diego last living
there uh my community was majority
Hispanic the people the legal Mexican
immigrants were the most thankful for
the wall they're like we came we came
the right way they should have to come
the right way they should be able to do
this we recently went down to uh Tijuana
and uh when I was down there I was in an
Uber and the Uber driver was telling us
this story and it was kind of amazing to
be told this by an Uber driver in Mexico
he said that he lived for like two
decades in the United States his mom got
sick so he came home to see her but then
he couldn't get back in the country
because he had overstay his Visa he was
staying illegally when he was there and
so he worked with human traffickers he
literally said human traffickers and
they threw up a ladder where he climbed
40 feet up or whatever to this massive
wall near uh near San Diego and then
when the border patrol agents were
coming they panicked pulled the ladder
and ran and left him up there and he
fell down and broke his legs or whatever
and he got he fell back on the other
side and I'm just like it is insane that
this you these people feel like they can
just openly say these things about how
they're trying to come into the United
States breaking our laws but the other
crazy thing is the story is he's
basically saying the wall kept me out
wow
yeah works but Biden's recognizing it's
working how many federal things did he
wave in order to do this you say 26 26
federal laws in South Texas well Biden
is now losing to Trump in 10 of the 11
polls that the real clear politics
average counts and uh one of the major
issues is immigration and Trump beats
Biden on immigration 52 to 28 and so you
know the people are sick of what's
happening at the border and Joe Biden
recognizes it's going to be an absolute
bloodbath for them and the Democrats in
2024 if they don't at least pretend to
address this right right now the polls
that have Biden up are the outliers so
if you do a poll and you find Joe Biden
is ahead you should if you are
responsible report to your audience this
must be an anomalous poll so when the
ABC Washington Post poll came out with
10 with Trump up 10 points they said
this is clearly an outlier it's it's a
blip ignore it ignore it and it's like
well you know fair point it is 10 points
is a big heavy swing a lot of ties and
Trump seems to be winning more than he's
losing so at this point if we're going
to hold up that same standard with Biden
according to yugov up five that's an
outlier we shouldn't we should consider
it to be incorrect because Trump's
actually winning almost every other poll
yeah and the Democrats know this uh you
can tell because they've arrested Trump
four times uh and they're changing their
tune on immigration well you see you
know what they're doing now with with
the fraud lawsuit they I I I I believe
they will seize as much of Trump's
assets as possible with this method they
can't just come out and strip Trump of
his net worth of his of the things he
owns because then you know there's going
to be questions about whether or not we
actually live in a country anymore but
here's what we've seen so far with the
judge the judge summarily decrees
without hearing any evidence and
rejecting actual evidence proving Trump
was innocent and says the Trump
organization overvalued its properties
Mara Lago is only worth $18 million
you've got real estate developers and
investors in Florida who are not
Republican and not political scoffing
and complaining be like what do you
think you're doing that's not true our
property is worth a lot of money and so
here's what happens right now the trial
that Trump is facing is to determine
whether or not he falsified business
records if the judge has already merily
decreed with no legal basis that Trump's
properties are not actually worth what
the bank claimed and what he claimed and
the appraisers claimed it's kind of a
bold thing for someone to do but the
judge said no no no I'm the one who's
going to determine what your property is
worth it's only 10 million not 100
million okay now they're going to go to
court and and Trump's going to be like
here are the documents and the judge is
going to go that document says the
building's worth 100 million but we've
already determined it's only worth 10
million that means you falsified a
document guilty you are hereby liable
for fraud against the state of New York
and you now owe us $250 million we'll
start by seizing that gigantic Tower
that's only worth $10 million you see
what they're doing by claiming maral
Lago is worthless when they file to
seize Trump's assets because he owes
them $250 million they're going to use
that to seize
everything that's the game so I think
the next move they'll make is we will
hear that Donald Trump is found liable
to fraud because he falsified records
he'll he'll owe the state or or some you
know regulatory firm or whatever $250
million cuz it's Laticia James who's
following the suit then they're going to
seize a a $500 million property but
claim it's worth $10 million and say
okay now you owe us another 240 and
they'll keep doing it until Trump has
nothing left it's sick what's happening
and there's there's no jury in this case
it is a Democrat activist judge who's
who smiling in the camera who's a
Democrat it's a a complete show and
you know we can't let this we can't let
this stand well I think there's no jury
intentionally I think Trump doesn't want
a jury a New York jury is just going to
rule against you it's a waste of time
it's the Trump team probably knows if
they went for a jury trial they'd end up
losing either way but this time it would
actually cost them you know $30 million
in in a legal battle their attitude
probably right now is the judge has has
actually done Trump a favor with the
summary judgment because now Trump is
going to appeal he's been planning to
appeal he needs to get it outside of you
know uh of of New York City basically
and that's where his actual chance of
winning is going to be don't waste time
and money with a jury trial let the
judge say what he says and then you can
appeal and the judge made the mistake of
being a and saying I'm going to
summary judgment marag was worthless
yeah now Trump's got all of the all the
room to appeal and be like there is no
sane reasonable human who thinks it's
fraud when the third party when the
external party that you're doing a deal
with has determined the value for you
they're claiming it's fraud that Donald
Trump had that that Trump Donald Trump
bought a property or that he found a
property went to a bank and he said to
the bank I want to buy this property the
bank sends out a third party appraiser
who then says to the bank it's worth you
know $100 million and then Trump goes
you got it they that's fraud what it if
if you come out and reject the the the
appraisal from the appraiser third party
and like submit separate documents and
like falsified documents okay there's a
question if they want to come out and
make those claims sure but for the time
being the judge has rejected any hearing
based on the facts and the Trump
organization says they have testimony
from their lenders who are thanking like
they're saying they made us a lot of
money it was a good deal $40 million in
interest the banks got yeah well and
like appraisals are helpful but still at
the end of the day real estate is worth
whatever anybody's willing to pay for it
and nobody with their right mind would
say that Maraga would be sold for $18
million today it's 28 Acres beautiful
real EST 1.5 sorry 17.5 and right on the
ocean has Lake access it's both ocean
access I I just learned it's got a
tunnel under the road yeah to get out to
the beach club wow I learned this I
learned this we learned this from L
Trump the other day Mara laga I I'm such
an idiot it literally means from the
ocean to the to the Lagoon yeah and I
was like oh duh Mar Lago ocean 2 Lagoon
a property a property right down the
road
just their land I think sold for like
$400 million just a bunch of trees oh
dude like 30.3 acres is 10510 million
Ken Griffin bought a similar lot the
size of mar Lago for about 400 or500
million and and so just the lot alone is
worth hundreds of millions of dollars on
top of that Mar Lago is a functioning
profitable business and so like who made
the affirmative action attorney general
a real estate expert overnight like
she's clueless and I'm glad she was dumb
enough to post this you know like
campaign style graphic on her Twitter
account she's getting ratioed into
Oblivion I think there's like 14,000
comments on it saying that she's an
idiot which she is um but it's just sad
what they're putting these people
through and um let's let's talk about
some other people being put through some
stuff from Politico lawyers bail on my
pillows Mike Lindell saying he owes
millions in fees and Mike Lindell is
saying he is facing multiple IRS audits
this is what happens when you go up
against corruption there are evil people
in government there have been for a long
time they are working in intelligence
agencies they are abject evil their
goals are for self-preservation and for
self-benefit and if you exercise your
rights as an American they will do
everything they can to destroy you don't
take my word for it how about Chuck
Schumer six ways from Sundays if you
piss them off is that the American way
that the intelligence agencies run this
country and you have no right you have
no say and only by their good graces are
we allowed to function in society I
reject that yeah I I mean we know that
IRS has a very bad record especially
when it came to going after people for
political purposes especially under the
Obama Administration which they were
caught red-handed doing I I think it's
fair to say that that's exactly what's
happening right now to to Mike lell and
uh he's not the first one I think what
happened to Alex Jones's the first kind
of financial attack and cancellation
that is being utilized by the system and
establishment to try to bleed out the
resources try to stop any kind of uh of
just power and authority from human
beings being able just to speak out just
to be able to silence them by taking
away all of their money all of their
resources has been let's be honest here
somewhat of an effective strategy by The
Establishment and it's a scary one
because you look at these stories you're
like am I going to get audited am I
going to be able to find lawyers as of
course lawyers are literally being
indicted as well um so it's it's just uh
I I think this is law fair I I think
this is a weaponized doj justice system
that has been financed and bankrolled by
George Soros who of course is
weaponizing District Attorneys all
throughout the United States and this is
why I think it's important to to live in
places that actually represent your
ideas not just because of the
possibility of this kind of lawfare but
if if there's even an incident where you
have to defend yourself you want a jury
that actually respects the right of
human beings to prot protect themselves
a lot of democratic places don't have
that at all they have district attorneys
that will punish you for just even
standing up for yourself which is crazy
it's mindboggling well this is also less
than two weeks after American Express
came out and said that they were
severely limiting Michael lindell's
credit limit yeah and that's what his
business relies on like he's he's making
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
in revenue and has a very functioning
business servicing millions of Americans
so what you're seeing here is
weaponization of government and also the
weaponization of private Enterprise
together in tandem to someone because of
his political views what's severely
ironic about all of this is that the
progressive authoritarians in society
that conduct this type of Madness will
accuse us of being fascists when the
actual definition of fascism is an
authoritarian government and private
Enterprise partnering together to stifle
the views of political opposition that's
exactly what's happening here and they
want to send a very loud message that if
you dare speak up as a business owner or
as a politician or as a community leader
or as a podcast host or whatever it
might be if you dare speak up they will
weaponize private public Enterprise
against you and your values and your
family they're doing it to Rudy Giuliani
I mean it's it's absurd what's happening
I don't know if any of you have met Mike
but Mike is one of the nicest kindest
and most generous people I've ever met
in my life he's he's uh always wants to
be helpful he always tries to build
people up you know he's been financially
impactful on so many lives of
conservatives you know a lot of
conservatives have a hard time finding
advertisers and Mike Lindell was right
there to step up and so not only are
they going after after Mike they're
going after all of those people that
he's supporting Steve Bannon one of his
big advertisers is my pillow if you look
at a lot of these podcasters my pillow
like subsidizes a lot of these people
when there was a boycott on Tucker
Carlson it was Miche Lindell that
stepped up and said I'm going to promote
my pillows on the Tucker Carlson show
you know what I mean at a certain point
people can only have so many pillows
right what you but it's princip build a
pillow fort she has like 40 pillows on
her bed but I think it was just so many
Americans saw what they were doing to
Mike canceling him because of his
political beliefs and and I think that's
why Public Square has been such a rocket
to the moon um because people want to
shop with their values and say maybe I
need three pillows or four pillows every
three months now and just because I want
to support Mike Lindell because this guy
sacrific a lot just because you know and
so well he's got towels and bathrobes
and slippers B not just pillows I'm just
you know is he on Public Square he is
and uh we're actually he's he's we're
we're becoming close uh he's he's an
amazing man I Echo Alex's thoughts this
is a part of a broader theme too of
canceling advertisers we saw with Rumble
two weeks ago in the whole Russell Brand
thing Burger King hellofresh pulling so
something we're trying to do at Public
Square we have 70,000 plus small
businesses that all want to advertise in
the parallel economy so now we're trying
to push them to creators and say hey
you've got now creators a network of
advertisers that will not cancel you
here's the next thing you do you're
already you're probably already doing it
and you are doing it to a certain extent
is create the backend portal for social
media networking so then the the thing
people need to understand about YouTube
is that the bulk of the revenue you
YouTubers get is not from big companies
from small companies small a small Diner
in a local area with a few thousand
people will spend 50 bucks putting out
ads so that the videos appear and then
if you're you know you're living in this
town and you're watching a YouTube video
the commercial you see will for will be
for lose Diner down the street and
they're only spending 50 bucks but when
you add all of those little diners you
the YouTube creator end up getting a
couple Grand or something like that
creating that uh there there have been a
bunch of attempts at this throughout in
the past where companies have popped up
and said if you're a YouTubers sign up
and then we connect you with sponsors
that are looking for Content or whatever
the only problem is YouTube had
automated it yep the issue now is
advertisers are pulling out of YouTube
activists are threatening people to try
and get advertisers pulled so I think I
don't know if you guys are already if
you're already working on it but if you
sign up and you say like hey I make
content then you can see people being
like our budget for advertising this
month is 25 to 50 bucks here's what
we're looking to promote and then you
basically like accept and then message
them and then boom now you've got an
automated system for people who make
content to make money and promote
products build that parallel economy
it's a brilliant idea because you have
literally tens of thousands of
businesses across the country that have
felt disenfranchised rejected by Yelp
Google Trip Advisor these platforms are
no longer built for the interests of
small businesses especially not ones
that have conservative leanings and so
they asking us every day how do we get
more involved in the parallel economy
when they see budlight and Target tank
that $30 billion doesn't just eviscerate
it's got to go
somewhere right well and so if you can
if you can actually shift the
advertising world to be one that's
cancel proof like and then the parallel
economy can kind of broker all those
interactions like it's a very powerful
impenetrable force hey look uh Ultra
right conservative dad's beer what what
did what did Seth Sell like 2 million
bucks and like 12 hours after the Trump
picture half a million in 12 hours a
million within like a day or two and
then he says by the time he closes out
it'll be like $2 million amazing man
just I just want everybody to listen
okay cuz you know a lot of people are
like how do I succeed in life and you
got so many people that are willing to
dump thousands of dollars into these
get-rich quick programs where like
you'll go to a seminar and a guy's like
I'm going to teach you the secrets to
success and here's a dude Seth weather's
like Bud light's nasty so I'm going to
sell beer and now he just sold a couple
million dollars worth of beer so if
you're looking how to what to do help
build the parallel economy invest in a
small business or a product do what you
can to say f you to the the corporations
that despise you Mike lell paved the way
yeah it's true and they hate him for it
you know there's so many creators that
probably would never have been able to
get their voices heard if it weren't for
Mike and uh you know Mike's a patriot
and we'll pray for him and uh it's sick
what they're doing to the guy but I know
the guy's a fighter and he's a man of
faith and so I I think he he knows he'll
get out of this but they've been putting
this guy through hell for three years
now well they did the same to Alex Jones
and Alex Jones is very persistent he's
he's still able to survive there's also
a lot of lawsuits happening right now
against Tucker Carlson there's another
big lawsuit against Elon Musk so these
people are being attacked I believe in a
coordinated way to try to of course
stifle any kind of resistance any kind
of speech Against The Establishment so I
don't think a lot of these inces or or
coincidences I do think there is
something top down happening here are
you guys working on any kind of like
social component cuz we've had people
ask us about that yeah to a degree um
the world of social commerce is growing
a lot like you even see Tik Tok starting
to play with some Commerce ideas um
which is a disaster in just a Chinese
data mining Farm but that said we have
uh the desire to get more into the world
of Connecting People locally to
businesses and other consumers where you
can actually like follow a local
business get exclusive discounts you're
following local businesses and be a part
of kind of the cast Brew Network right
so you're a part of a local Club
essentially that is partnered in loyalty
to these different businesses the the
other thing that's interesting and you
bring this up and my encouragement to
any young entrepreneurs people that are
fascinated in the parallel economy
over12 trillion do in assets are going
to transfer in the next eight years
between the baby boomer run businesses
down to the Next Generation 12 trillion
in assets so we have two options one is
those baby boomer run businesses can
either disappear into the ether that's
awful they can be bought up by
Blackstone on the private Equity side
and transformed against our values or
they can be purchased by Patriots and
turned into incredible sources for the
parallel economy my my recommendation go
on like acquire. comom there are all
these sites where these small businesses
are up for sale and if you're good at
marketing and you can grow like you can
purchase a business for
$2,000 and transform at sales and now
all of a sudden you have this incredible
tool to capitalize on the need for
Americans to have alternative Solutions
now you can only really do that if
you're genuine like you have to actually
believe in it otherwise no we should
hone in on this because throughout human
history it has always been predominantly
private Enterprise business and
capitalism that has saved people from
the woes and problems that the
government has started and I truly do
believe that voting with your dollar is
way more important than voting every
four freaking years you have a choice
you could support C Brew you could
support the weer change. shop you you
could support businesses made in America
on public Street or you could support
the pope rild inclusive capitalism ESG
Black Rock scams that are screwing you
over and literally taking your money and
running psychological operations and a
war against you in the fifth generation
this is something that I think people
need to understand now more than ever
you're if you're buying Starbucks if
you're buying Netflix if you're buying
from Disney what are you doing what
money where are you putting your energy
towards what are you getting in response
that usually seed oils usually usually
harmful stuff you could be supporting so
many different companies so many
different organizations and allowing
ideas to be sponsored by your energy I
can help I can help I want everyone to
to close your eyes and I want you to
imagine this right now when you go to a
woke Corporation imagine as you enter
the store that there is a gigantic
morbidly obese disgusting hideous
creature with mustard stains and grease
all over its face going give me more and
you're like sounds good and you're
handing money but next door there is a
glistening ripped Donald Trump saying
give me your money and we will support
American values you can make that choice
what do you want you want the disgusting
morbidly obese body positivity
purple-haired monster or 63 213 Donald
Trump can we just do a small mom and pop
business that's just me personally but
you know I don't want to get no erotica
here you okay the next door is a humble
local family there and there's and
there's the the nice old man who says
you know my grandfather started this
business and he gave it to my dad who
gave it to me and we're just here to
make sure you get the products you need
now our milk is fresh there's no seed
oils or high fructose corn syrup in any
of our food and it's readily available
right for you that's that's like a
component of the American dream this
like view of the wholesome farmer you
come in it's your neighbor he's got that
Farm Fresh butter for you he says howy I
you know you know what you know you know
it's like I feel really bad for people
in cities cuz we live you know we're out
in the Tri State like we're we're in the
western uh the Eastern panhandle of West
Virginia we can drive in any direction
10 minutes and there is a farm where
they're quite literally like here is
fresh butter right from the cow and it's
the most delicious butter you'll ever
have all grass-fed n grass-fed and
finished and uh a lot of these place cuz
the laws will have what we call Pet milk
it's milk it's raw right from the cow
but it's for Animals cuz it's not for
human consumption but of course people
will buy it and they'll drink it you
live in a city you know what you people
do they go to specialty stores and pay a
premium to buy real food because the
average food a person buys is plastic
garbage isn't that crazy plastic or
inflammatory or designated to destroy
your hormones and your endrin system
there's a biological War happening right
now that a lot of people don't even
realize to how horrible a lot of the
substances at the supermarket are
there's so many ingredients that are
banned all over the world but they're
okay here in the United States with a
corrupted FDA that has a revolving door
with Monsanto revolving door with all
the horrible corporations that do
factory farms and one of the best
decisions that I I I made in my life is
deciding I'm not going to go to the
supermarket there's a local Farm here I
support that local Farm I have a deal
with that local Farm I make sure I get
whatever I need uh from that local Farm
my money is in the community it's not
towards a a mega corporate giant that's
causing me inflammation and death and
cancer it's not even that where we live
we have so food outside just wild right
so paw season is is happening now and
we're on the way out you just have these
the they're in the I guess they're in
the mango family they call them
hillbilly banana and they're they just
big green fruits everywhere you grab
them right off the tree and you you
break it right open and it's like mango
and banana combined amazing people who
live in cities go to the grocery store
and they get high fructose corn syrup
flavored drink and it's a uh what what
is the beaver butt flavor we the
blueberry flavor was it I don't think
it's blueberry it's like strawberry or
something was it strawberry they the
artificial flavoring for a lot of these
these fruit drinks I think it's
strawberry comes from the anal glands of
a beaver used to used to used to yeah oh
used to well now it's probably worse now
it's probably like weird creepy
chemicals so like just think about this
man a little kid who lives in a city
walks into their Bodega Corner Store
whatever you want to call it and says
I'm thirsty and they look and sure
enough what do they have to to drink
they have little juices which is high
fructose corn syrup garbage Coca-Cola
garbage they look at what what do they
have to eat hoos ding-dongs Twinkies
plastic they put propylene glycol in
muffins at gas stations you know what
that is propylene glycol it's antifreeze
yeah and uh they'll argue yeah but
propylene glycol is the safe ethylene
glycol is the one that kills you and I'm
like I don't want to eat any freeze
either way where you when you live out
in the middle of nowhere you walk
outside and there's a wild fruit and
you're like looks good to me you eat it
now I recommend downloading the app
picture this you can scan a plant and it
will tell you if you actually can eat it
or not so don't just go eat random
plants random Beres but you can eat
leaves too mhm crazy I was reading about
how to survive in the wilderness and how
how to know if you can eat leaves and
there's like this process to it you take
a leaf you rip it in half and you rub it
on your skin and then you wait 15
minutes if nothing happens then you take
another Leaf you rip it in half and you
rub it on the side of your lip and if
nothing happens you take another Leaf
rip it in half chew on it spit it out
wait 15 minutes nothing happens you take
the leaf rip it in half chew on it
swallow it wait 15 minutes if nothing
happens congratulations you can need the
leaf but you eat a little bit you wait
and that's how you test it to see if
it's going to have like poison or
whatever but you can actually eat leaves
salads are scams just go straight for
the beef liver get an animal hunt it
down and uh there's a reason wild
animals always attack and the first
thing the first uh organ that they go
after is the liver well look look look
where we live we've got you know 20 some
odd deer just running around all over
the place they live on our front lawn
it's crazy it's a big you know 10 acre
property and uh they're just everywhere
but while I'm working and complain
complaining about Democrats the deer are
eating things growing and making more of
themselves yeah so they're doing hard
work every day to make sure there is
food readily available for me when I
choose to eat them and me I'm at home
complaining about the Democrats yeah I
just learned I just learned that
Chick-fil-A sauce is not good for you
it's horrible they brought it in here
and I'm like what are you doing I it
tastes so good so convenient it right
there that's because it's genetically
engineered to hit the pleasure sensors
of your mind while it destroys your gut
it destroys your immune system it
destroys your health it destroys your
your erectile function it destroys
everything it's horrible for you and it
causes huge amounts of inflammation uh
Chick-fil-A scam so many scams out there
it's it's be bewildering I I made it uh
an issue to look at all the ingredients
that are horrible for you I made a crap
list crap list is available for members
of Luken filter.com print it out put it
on your phone go to the supermarket and
then you just have to check you have to
look you have to read every ingredient
it's going to take a long time but
you're going to be very happy you do
this and you take charge of your health
by first of all being just a little bit
conscious about what you put down your
mouth hole you know what's really crazy
just real quick uh for the past several
years since uh 20 since 2014 the
basically the only thing I drink when I
go to a restaurant is I order a club
soda with a shot of lemon juice that's
best right yeah now these spin drifts
are everywhere everybody's buying them
and it's literally just club soda with
lemon juice in it there's no sugar and
I'm like how did that happen is like
this thing was becoming popular and
everyone just started doing this it's
weird you know do you have meal plans on
your website uh no we're we have we
actually have recipes um that we're
developing and working on as well that
are um you know healthy and and better
choices than of course what the average
American is told to eat because if you
listen to the to the FDA if you look at
the food pyramid that's a whole another
scam within a within a scam within a
scam of how just just absolutely
ridiculous it it says to eat like most
of your most of the food you should eat
is bread yeah makes the FDA classified a
a pizza as a vegetable yes back in 2011
I think that was Ino tomato sauce
they're literally poisoning poisoning
you to make you slow soft more more
gullible and more of an idiot to go
along with the programming and the bull
crap that they have for you what I love
about the pizza thing is that the the
the the argument was whether or not a
slice of pizza contained a serving of
vegetables and so the media made the
joke of they're arguing whether Pizza is
a vegetable that's not what happened it
was like it's got sauce on it does this
count as a serving and everyone's like
Tomato's fruit dude Tom tomato is not a
vegetable yeah the argument is kind of
irrelevant I guess but didn't they
utilize that to get cheaper meals in
school systems that you could get your
vegetable serving but it should have
been a serving of fruit yeah not serving
of vegetabl Michelle Obama's war on
chocolate milk was a disgrace and I
don't care if it's bad for you it tastes
delicious and every child has a right to
chocolate milk can you confirm is
chocolate milk bad it is yes yes what if
it's chocolate uh raw milk chocolate in
America is a lot different than
chocolate in Europe and if you ask a
European how American chocolate tastes
they're usually disgusted by it because
in America there's a preservative in
there that the government mandates a lot
of the chocolate companies to put in
there that is absolutely horrible and
unless you're used to eating it it
tastes like crap look you can get good
chocolate right they give you the actual
the cacao bean is broken up and they
I've W I went to this uh uh I went to a
place where they make it it was amazing
and they they take the little bits out
what are they called nibs yeah C nibs
yeah and then they they they they
pulverize it break it down melt it and
then you actually watch them like they
mix sugar in and stuff and so the dark
chocolate is just the nibs melted down
and then uh I don't know if they had
anything to it it's just like pure cacao
or whatever but then the problem with
chocolate in this country is it's not
really chocolate it's like
emulsifiers you know margarine and like
sugar cocoa flavor and sugar it's not
it's not real chocolate so chocolate
milk is typically what high fructose
corn syrup and chocolate flavored high
fructose corn syrup mixed into milk and
the milk is pus filled bacteria garbage
yeah one of the worst things that I
realized was really hindering my health
and I didn't realize it was really bad
for me was oat milk and almond milk I
thought yeah they're they're nut milks
they must be great for me and they're
absolutely horrible filled with high
fructose corn syrup filled with just a
lot of glyat a lot of horrible chemicals
that disrupt your gut and cause you a
lot of inflammation and a lot of damage
not just iral bowel syndrome but more
importantly there's a link between the
gut and the brain and if you destroy
your gut you're destroying your brain
which could explain why so many American
people are losing their minds and we
have a mental health crisis here in the
United States right now but again just
to go back to what we were talking about
from the beginning here every single
Choice every single decision you make
matters right now they're going after
everyone they're going after Mike
Lindell Tucker Carlson Elon Musk Alan
Alex Jones so it's it's more important
than ever you listening right now take
charge of your life and start voting
with your dollar consciously and
exercise let's pull this story up from
CNBC we got this they're coming after
Elon Musk as well SEC sues to force Elon
Musk to testify in Twitter probe they're
saying that he didn't uh he didn't
comply with his subena to testify he
failed to appear on September 15th 2023
the case is tied to musk's purchase of
Twitter last year and the stock trading
surrounding the acquisition this is the
game that's it that's the news if you in
any way stand against this failing and
corrupt establishment
they will in desperation do everything
they can to stop you but you know what I
see with this this is pathetic this is
sad back in the day we wouldn't get a
story about them forcing someone to
testify no one would dare defy them but
you know what I've been saying it's like
they have that saying that wealth only
lasts three generations well the people
who created the intelligence agencies
and ran them and knew what it took to
build them up have gave it to their kids
and their kids kids and the kids kids
have no idea how to make the machine
work and so it's falling apart good
riddens well and Elon in his defense
claimed hey I've already testified
numerous times about this acquisition
not only that it was probably the most
scrutinized acquisition of a public
company because anytime you're taking a
public company private I mean the
regulations to go through that process
especially when it's $44 billion
whatever it was they are they are
massive and Monumental and so this was
already the most scrutinized uh
acquisition in modern history he already
has been under the spotlight for this
and what really frustrates me about all
this is that the SEC is choosing to have
Elon testify meanwhile we still have
stuff revealed that has not been dealt
with from the Twitter files so instead
of actually handling the corruption that
was exposed under the previous
leadership of Twitter they're wanting to
subpoena the guy and Sue the guy who
actually is trying to bring all that
into the light and do their jobs for
them the SEC is a regulatory invest or
investigative body they're supposed to
be Gatekeepers and accountability people
for companies and yet Elon actually did
their job for them by investigating
malfant that was happening in a public
company so I it's just it he's the good
guy here and he's the one getting
punished for this and he stopped the
distribution of online child adult
behavior on the platform when there was
victims demanding Twitter take it down
Twitter knew there was adult content
with children in in very horrific
horrible ways and they knew who it was
they had the person they had the child
coming to them saying please take this
down and they refused Elon Musk came in
and then finally told people exactly
what was going on he's all in people to
speak freely and that's the issue here
he's actually doing something good that
allows people to find out what's really
happening in this world and therefore he
needs to be stopped and I'm pretty sure
that doj also opened an investigation
into Tesla was it yes and like they're
just harassing well they're going after
him for not hiring refugees even though
it's it's illegal to to hire people who
are not American citizens for your
company it doesn't matter what they're
going they're just going after him
they're just going after Mikel they're
just going after d
why because they are all opponents of
the current system and it's dangerous
time and the Newsweek article came out
about how the FBI is going to be closely
monitoring Trump allies and Trump
supporters as we get closer to the 2024
election they are trying to intimidate
us they are trying to break us uh but I
think the people are waking up I think
Joe you know Joe Rogan was talking about
the marago evaluation today he's like
these people aren't even trying to hide
they're you know anymore like
like they don't even care anymore um but
the American people I think are waking
up we need to continue to shed light on
what's Happening and I think people like
Elon is courageous he's not going to
back down I think he's going to stand
strong in the face of this President
Trump has obviously stood strong um but
it's sick and we can't let this stand
and I think whoever becomes the next
speaker of the house needs to deliver on
the promise of finally holding these
people
accountable yes how what are they going
to do though well you could start with a
subpoena how many subpoenas were sent in
so far in nine months not not too many
yeah um and so bring people before
Congress the January 6 committee I think
it was a complete and total farce but
they subpoena a thousand so-called
Witnesses and in their 900 page report
only like nine people were mentioned but
they had a thousand Witnesses they
harassed a thousand Trump allies just
for the hell of it meanwhile we actually
have real things that we can be going
after and we've sent out like two
subpoenas and so we need to actually
hold people accountable and uh I think
we have people on the Judiciary
Committee who want to get it done we
have people on Ways and Means and on um
oversight that want to get it done but
we just need blessing from the top and
so um we need to play by the rules of
the January 6 committee to we just need
speaker Trump there you go it's great
idea and if he flood the Zone like part
part of the thing is the SEC doesn't
actually think Elon would ever be guilty
of any of this they know this is all a
sham they know it's a joke just like
they know Mike Lindell nothing's going
to turn up in the audits he's a huge
company that's audited every year they
do it because they want to distract you
if they can distract the founder of
Tesla from his work they're hoping they
can throw you off course then
Republicans we claim civility so we
don't dare flood the Zone when we
actually have legitimate cases so we
could actually bring forth continual
judgments multiple every single day
against these corrupt actors and we
don't cuz we stay civil quote unquote
and uh it's not a winning strategy we
actually have the case on our side the
truth is on our side all of our
arguments have the virtue of being true
and so while the SEC is more
antagonistic and militant than we are
they have no legs to stand on and the
opposite is true for us so that's got to
change this is the problem with Kevin
McCarthy it was once again slow down
there Democrats Kevin McCarthy was
negotiating with them behind the backs
of the Republicans there was no point in
there being a majority
what do we have if the establishment
Republicans and the Democrats are the
exact same thing it's funny because the
Democrats are like here's what we
overtly want the Republicans are like
hey all those things are really bad all
right is nobody looking okay let's go
vote for those things we really want so
it's got to change and you know I don't
know if it ends up with Trump as a
speaker it'd be great it'd be a dream
come true but I'll take obstruction over
them doing the exact same thing they you
know over and over and over again and
nothing happening I think I think
outside of that is the right for too
long I think one of the reasons we're
seeing this change is Donald Trump lit
up a bunch of people who normally did
not vote and have a different worldview
than your TR traditional conservative
conservatives were always like well we
must maintain decorum and play by the
rules and then Trump came in and was
like Rosie OD is a fat pig and you
didn't say it like that exactly but all
of a sudden the cor was on its head and
regular people who never voted before
were all of a sudden finding themselves
align with the Republicans Republicans
got pissed like oh well I never and so
now you're seeing Fighters you're seeing
people I remember I was at an Occupy
Wall Street March in Chicago and it was
like one of these ancillary like
protests they were doing and they
marched through uh South Hallstead and
it was the funniest thing ever to see
these Southside irish guys just start
punching these activists and it's like
they the these leftists had this idea
that we're the working class and we are
right and the actual workingclass white
dudes in the south side of Chicago were
like you're the elite scumbags causing
our problems get out of our neighborhood
and they're like no we're here for human
and this dude just takes his shirt off
and he like nope and I'm like well I
certainly don't encourage that kind of
stuff it is interesting to see these are
the kind of people that I think Donald
Trump actually woke up these are the
white working class who felt left behind
and as Michael Moore said Trump was the
human Molotov cocktail they were going
to lob into the system so now what ends
up happening is these people are voting
for the likes of mad Gates and they're
voting for other people like them and
they want aggression they want someone
to get into Congress and be more
aggressive and more assertive and make
demands yeah well The Establishment Tred
to primary Meads this last cycle in
2022 and uh I they they put a lot of
money behind this guy I think like 2
million bucks or something like that and
Matt beat him 82 to 20 or 82 to 18 or
something like that it was no
contest like the establishment has so
much money to just blow trying to take
the heads of our Fighters and that is
why Republicans have such a hard time
like Blake Masters for example was such
a great I thought a really great guy and
a great POS a great candidate but you
spent so much money fighting him in the
primary you had one establishment guy
who put in like 20 million bucks to
fight him in the primary and then the
general comes around and Blake Masters
is outspent 3 to one four to one k Lakes
same situation $25 million against Carri
Lake in a primary underfunded the
general the way it's supposed to work is
you vote for your Republican who goes to
Congress and says we don't want you know
these books in our schools and the lader
ship says you got it we'll ban it
tomorrow just sign War funding funding
for Ukraine funding for Afghanistan and
they go you got a bus so there are
certain things that you must stand by
and then you can maybe get a little a
little morsel here and there and so
we've got a bunch of people go to
Congress and they're basically like
peasants on their knees begging may I
have another crumb sir from The
Establishment Elites who are like I'll
give you your crumb but you must give me
my billion dollars for bombs and they go
yep I don't want to fight it's too scary
you know so far in this Republican
primary for
president both primaries democrat or
republican the Democrats have spent $35
million on ads and on the Republican
side $139 million has been spent
$125 of that or 120 million of that has
been against Trump and Trump is at 65%
and everybody else is in single digits
now wow and so and the voting doesn't
start for three more months and so we're
going to continue the establishment
don't ERS are going to continue to light
money on fire because they hate Trump
and then we're going to be severely
underfunded come the general election
because of the people's selfishness and
the hatred of not just Trump but the
people that he brought into the party
and so the Democrats are just sitting
back laughing at these Jokers that are
running and you know the the finances
are actually incredibly important when
it comes to elections well let's let's
talk at what's at stake here from The
Daily Mail Putin threatens the West with
total nuclear destruction leaving no
chance of survival in the event of a
strike on Russia as he warrants his
Satan 2 and flying Chernobyl missiles
are ready for use in ranting anti- us
speech was it worth it is is is is is is
Ukraine really worth this we don't want
Russia to have access to the Black Sea
we want to cut them off and take control
of the of the oil and gas so we are
risking war with a nuclear power and all
these people they come on they say it's
a good thing because Russia's been
weakened I don't I that's not a good
thing if Russia is weakened to the point
where they're scared they have nukes do
you want to back like okay you see a
rabbit right not scary at all huh you
back a rabbit into a corner the amount
of fear you have for that circumstance
goes up just a little bit rabbit still
scariest thing in the world but now that
it's backed into a corner it might
actually try and attack you or bite you
and scratch you and then who knows you
get rabies or something from I don't
know rabbit's going to have rabies but
you don't want to do that right maybe
you don't care because you got to catch
the rabbit Vladimir Putin is a dude with
a bunch of nuclear weap and they're like
let's back a guy with nukes into a
corner to the point where he says my
only option is total Annihilation M and
this is the game you get when you get
members of Congress who outright just
say we will cut deals to fund War so
long as you give me my minor victories
and make sure I don't get fired for my
job yeah this is um a very um crazy
situation that a lot of people have been
warning about as of course the majority
of people don't want war the only people
who vote for the war are the members of
Congress that in my opinion should be
going there and then fighting it if you
really want this war go out there and
fight it the argument that Russia has
been weakened is also being challenged
by a lot of individuals who are bringing
up the success of bricks and the larger
relationship that Russia now has with
India with China with Saudi Arabia and
its other energy distribution that now
they're moving around the world selling
it to other countries who are now
selling it back to Europe at a premium
so if you look at exactly what's
happening here this isn't just a
Devastation because of of the
possibility of a nuclear war this is
already Devastation for the people of
Ukraine that have started to draft women
into the military this is already a
Devastation for the world's poorest
people since there's a food supply
shortage this is already a horrible
situation for all the people in Europe
who are poor because now their energy
prices are going to be skyrocketing
especially if Europe has a dark winter
which they're expected to have which of
course will obliterate and destroy
family's ability to live and survive as
Germany is now going back on coal of all
things which is just just ridiculous
this conflict needs to be stopped there
needs to be day taunt there needs to be
negotiations no side is going to get
everything that they want but at least
we could stop the madness of human
beings dying for politicians and
oligarchs and corrupted individuals that
take everything for themselves and don't
give it back to anyone else there's so
many reports of Frontline Ukrainian
soldiers not having the proper Year
we're giving $200 plus million a day to
Ukraine $200 plus million every single
day of your money is going over there
where is it going to well according to
CBS News only about 30% of that goes to
the actual people they retracted that
but according to some estimates that
looks like that's the actual number
which just so much corruption happening
in that country as zalinsky just fired a
lot of the key members of his defense
Ministry which you never do during the
middle of a war why did he do it well we
don't know the the the official
explanation has not been given to us but
I think it's pretty clear it has to deal
with corruption at the highest levels of
oligarchs coming in there enriching
themselves when sending some of their
youngest poorest people to go fight for
their Ambitions which is stupid well we
know they want an endless war but what's
so ominous and dangerous about this is
that when they wanted an endless war in
Iraq they used weapons of mass
destruction as the pretext for it when
we knew that that wasn't legitimate now
it's interesting because they want they
want an endless war against an adversary
that actually does have weapons of mass
destruction
verifiably and we think that we run no
risk of pushing them to the edge it
makes no sense like we were fighting
goat farmers in Afghanistan and Iraq now
we're fighting Putin who's literally
coming on here I didn't sign up for this
war did any of you want this war did
Congress vote on this war and what's
obnoxious is that Democrats came out
after the speaker turn turnover and now
they're saying we will not back anybody
that does not prioritize Ukraine funding
as one of the highest priorities not
once did they mention a peace deal like
zinsky comes to Congress we could have
said dude you do not step foot on
American soil until your number one
priority is a peace deal no more
aggression well they had peace deals but
then the US came in and sabotaged those
peace deals as of course this is a
banker war and it's a it's not only a
Forever War it's a limited Forever War
it's a Henry Kissinger Doctrine that's
being practiced right now and and we're
reaching a point where the ukrainians
are running out of human beings that's
how sad that's how tragic that's how
many lives were lost in this entire
debacle which shouldn't have happened in
the first place yes you could put some
blame on Russia yes put some blame on
Ukraine and NATO I don't care just stop
stop with this stupid War stop with the
Bloodshed stop with the life loss you're
fighting over destroyed territories
you're fighting over politicians saying
I want to tax these people that's
essentially what this war is about which
is insane crazy is the person that was
labeled the Russian puppet president
Trump he was the only president that
Vladimir Putin didn't invade another
country under you know under Bush it was
Georgia under Obama it was Crimea and
under Biden it's Ukraine now president
Trump so Crimea is Ukraine so Ukraine
twice Ukraine twice right but president
Trump he sanctioned the nordstream 2
pipeline the first thing one of the
first things that Biden did
was restart the nordstream 2 pipeline in
Russia empowered Russia and then blew it
up and caused one of the biggest
national disasters in world history but
also I I want to counter back a little
bit on Donald Trump because his foreign
policy with Ukraine also wasn't that
good as he had a lot of State Department
old heads coming in and he allowed them
to pretty much do whatever they wanted
to do Trump uh actually went further
than Barack Obama was even willing to by
sending lethal weapons to Ukraine he set
that very dangerous president which led
us to this current situation he now
currently is speaking up he did say he
would be the the the president that
stops the war immediately which is why I
think he's getting a lot of support but
also at the same time he is saying the
United States shouldn't be paying for
this war European countries need to be
paying for this war so there's a little
bit of a conflicting message that I wish
he would clear up and become more
president on uh and and explain exactly
how he would do all of this because
um there's an easy way to do this but I
I I want Trump to at least explain it
and make his stance more solidified
because he's kind of wavering a little
bit in my opinion well I think president
Trump's track record when he was in
office and the fact that there wasn't a
war uh speaks a ton of volume the fact
no new Wars the fact that Putin didn't
move on Ukraine we were very close
towards a war with Iran and he did bomb
Syria according to his own son because
Ivanka Trump cried to him about the
Syrian gas attacks which were false flag
attacks which
son um I'll get i'll get to the exact s
listen listen listen baby Trump's not
perfect but I I mean a strategy for
withdrawal from from Syria withdrawal
from Afghanistan which were botched
botched by the way the the state
department lying to the American people
and Donald Trump but the Abraham Accords
were good his his his efforts towards
peace and North Korea was amazing he
worked on a lot of peace with no new
Wars the North Korea stuff was great but
then he brought in that came in and said
that North Korea is following the Libyan
model which really pissed off North
Korea and then destroyed any kind
negotiations I I don't think we're going
to get this libertarian dream of a
president who's going to come in and
solve everything overnight but it is
undeniable that Donald Trump's foreign
policy was actually good based on the
situation that we are in well and he
listened to intelligence too much he's
got to trust his guy I mean when
intelligence lies to him blatantly about
what's happening on the ground in
Afghanistan in order to Halt a
withdrawal that they then botched a year
later lat you know I our intelligence
operation in the United States was
behind all this you know he gets briefed
Every Morning by the intelligence
apparatus that sits in a room and says
Mr President if you move the embassy to
Jerusalem there will be nuclear war from
Iran he said nah not going to listen did
it no nuclear war peace and when he
would trust his gut and actually not
listen to John boltons of the world
there was a natural inclination toward
peace because I think that's uh who the
guy is I mean honestly he truthed what
was it a month ago I just want all the
dying to stop like I just I want Dy to
stop on both sides I'll be honest I I
think out of all the candidates I think
Vivic has one of the best kind of
foreign policies out there but second to
him I will admit it is Donald Trump
because he's still one of the few people
willing out willing to to have an
anti-war kind of sentiment which is rare
and when you look at the entire
Republican ticket DeSantis doesn't want
to talk about Ukraine he doesn't give
any answers about what he would do in
Ukraine he flipflops on it a lot and
it's very concerning to see so many
neoconservative kind of align with him
as well so I I I would say you know
Donald Trump again not perfect I think
he does deserve to be criticized on some
of his foreign policy but out of what we
have I think he's one of the best well
did you watch The Bill O'Reilly Tucker
Carlson interview uh no I didn't so Bill
ory disclosed something that I wasn't
aware of or a lot of people weren't
aware of but he was involved in a
conversation with President Trump
talking about designating the drug
cartels as um as a terrorist
organization and he was super close to
doing it and he got like legal Authority
and all these people in he got the
military in and Bill O'Reilly was also
in these conversations according to his
his testimony to the Tucker and you know
so president Trump calls up the
president of Mexico and he says I'm
going to
designate the cartels as a terrorist
organization and we're going to go take
him out and the President says please
don't do that we're going to have that's
going to cause serious problems for me
and so the president of Mexico and then
Trump they end up striking a deal where
Mexico sends their troops to the border
at both the northern border to our
country and also to the southern
countries to prevent and legal migration
was down 80% because of this deal so he
did not end up going through with
designating them as a terrorist
organization he looked at it as a
negotiation tactic and he got 80% of
illegal migration to stop because of
that that deal and so uh he doesn't want
to disclose what his plan would be with
Putin and zalinski but he does have
personal relationships with both of them
there was not a conflict when he was
president and so when he says I am the
guy that has the ability to end this war
I believe him I hope so I I do agree as
well I think I think the day they
announc Trump's the winner before he's
even president the fighting stops yeah I
mean I I still can't get over the fact
that he met with Kim jung-un I mean that
that alone like it was going places it
could have been great and let me and let
me let me clarify he didn't just meet
with Kim Jong-un Donald Trump crossed
into an enemy Nation with no security
detail in a in a show of good faith and
peace with their with their leader the
media attacked him for it this move
nearly brought tears in my eyes I was
like Donald Trump is a brave mfer I mean
look he's holding the cards he's like
North Korea is not going to attack me
they're not going to kidnap me but what
president is going to be like security
stand back I am now going to be under
the jurisdiction of an ation cuz I want
them to understand peace we're serious
about it they insult him for it and I
was I was I was talking to some I was
hanging out uh this was at I think this
was at seminal last time we were here in
uh in Florida at the Hard Rock playing
poker and uh it it came the Pol politics
came up and then some guy made a crack
about Donald Trump supporters and then
someone laughed and they pointed to me
and they were like this guy likes Trump
and I was like yeah he's pretty good I'd
vote for him and then he's like you
don't the other guy goes you don't
seriously mean that do you and I was
like yeah I do goes why and I was like
oh boy boy foreign policy no new Wars
withdrawal strategies from Syria and
Afghanistan I grew up in a time when we
were mad about that stuff and then I
said but honestly you know for me with
my family history seeing him make the
effort to bring peace to the Korean
Peninsula was was inspirational and the
fact that he crossed the DMZ with no
security detail nearly brought tears to
my eyes and he goes that never happened
and I'm like you live in crackpot Wally
World all day and night dude if you want
to hate the man that bad by all means go
ahead and do so but I'm like and then
someone else the guy to my left he goes
that really happened I took up my phone
I played the video I'm like there's a
video of Donald Trump crossing the
demilitarized zone in North Korea into
North Korea with the North Korean
dictator and his military with no
security detail because he said I am
serious about peace with you well right
after president Trump won in 16 he met
with Obama and Obama said you know
president Trump what's our biggest
threat Obama said North Korea World War
III started by North Korea and president
Trump kept that in the back of his mind
his entire presidency he like I'm going
to accomplish this goal I'm going to
bring peace and he did so with
tremendous push back and you know now
did he bring peace it did it didn't last
but like well John Bolton his own member
that he appointed ruined it epically and
really pushed North Korea away yeah I
don't think John Bolton's coming back in
I in round two we're living in a crazy
world I hope not but who you like to see
but there but there was a war there was
a war in East Ukraine um during his
presidency there was limited fighting
Tulsi Gabbert I'm critical of everyone
I'm sorry A lot of people are like you
know calling me out in the chat here
it's fine but I'm I'm critical of
everyone including telsey Gabbert who's
a member of the Council on Foreign
Relations so uh I think and also endorse
Joe Biden by the way so so I think yeah
I I think we we have to have a level of
realism here and and critique here
that's um not emotional but based off
real conversations that could check our
ourselves our power our side and be able
to uh have real conversations that could
say hey I I don't agree with this I I
think we could do better because I think
we can do better who's somebody that you
wouldd like to see as a national
security adviser um melice not John
Bolton definitely def definitely not him
but there's a lot of um there's a lot of
very uh interesting individuals um I
think it was General um McCormick um and
uh General McGregor that I that I think
would be uh that would be pretty good um
I I could give you a full list of names
but I would have to look into my kind of
roller decks of individuals that I
listen to um personally I think
McGregor's phenomenal yeah I think
McGregor would be would be really good
in that situation and has a realistic
sense of of what's really going on and
people I don't know I don't think so but
he would be great he would be great to
have on the show well everybody we're
going to go to super chats so if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel send in your
super chats we're going to be reading
your questions and head over to
timcast.net saying how did people howdy
howd thanks for the Super
Chat RJ McDougle Heim says laid off
because the economy they took my der
thanks Joe Biden yo look Co was messed
up you can blame you can Co was under
trump it was under Biden so I'll just
say moot point but 2019 under Trump
ain't nobody was complaining also check
out red balloon go to Red balloon. org
great partner of ours largest non-woke
job board in the country awesome Yep
very cool highly recommend Let's see we
got Raymond g Stanley say Tim mad folks
in my feeds will be in Miami tomorrow
it's going to be great getting all of
our folks together I call dibs on
ding-dong ditching Ronda sucks no no
nobody ding on Ditch I like dis antis I
just don't like his campaign it's it's
it's it's just apocalyptic you know
there I saw a video that was retweeted
earlier uh Dave rubben retweeted it and
it it's it's a good video it's Ronda
sandz talking about all the things they
got done it's not insulting Trump it's
not it's not you know telling everybody
bad things about other people it's a
video talking about the good things he
did and I'm like it's so great all the
things he did so why do the prediction
markets have him under Nikki Haley
whatever you look at in terms of his
policy policy does not win you elections
it is inspirational and we like it but
if you don't have all these other
characteristics and namely Charisma I am
not speaking right now specifically
about uh desantis's capabilities I'm
saying Charisma is the trait your
campaign needs and the DeSantis campaign
their Charisma is zero it's not just
that DeSantis comes off a little stodgy
he can improve on that and he has
tremendously and I respect it but it's
that the people he's hired to run his
campaign lack influence and Charisma and
just don't get it and what they the you
know I heard from people on Twitter they
said uh they responded to me saying it's
kind of obvious anybody who's wor their
salt in in influence and Charisma is
behind Donald Trump so if you're trying
to run a campaign and you're trying to
hire people unless you have that X
Factor VI has it unless you have that
you're hiring the B Team you're hiring
the people that Trump didn't want and
all the good people are working for the
campaign they think he's going to win or
they're just buy it I mean if we want to
be real the idea for of people acting
like Ronda santz still as a
shot you know look there's always
there's always a possibility he could
turn things around and we're a year away
so it's an eternity but when the
prediction markets take you from the
front runner to underneath Nikki Haley
what that means is confidence among
people in politics for your candidacy is
gone and fourth place is yunan who's not
even running to be fair V is now in
fifth place in the in in predicted so
he's not doing too well either you hate
to see it it is what it is I mean there
is one person with influence who is
behind Ronda santz and his name is Bill
Mitchell and he's a great guy and he's
not an aging lesbian I want to make it
very clear well it's his own it's to be
fair you know he's the one who said it
yeah that's your words and then you know
that's that's I I just think you know it
was really funny though he he said it
and then he goes as soon as I said it I
realized they were going to clip it and
I'm like well yeah you know that's what
you get but all right let's read some
more Shane H Wilder says the Biden admin
allowing construction of the border wall
ah the fall leaves are turning white
girls are buying pumpkin spice lattes
you can almost smell the election season
in the air well we're a year away but
yes yeah but uh you know casper.com has
pumpkin spice all year round so
Congressman Troy Nells says just had a
great conversation with President Trump
about the speaker race he is he is
endorsing Jim Jordan a no and I believe
Congress should listen to the leader of
our party Sean henned also said
something similar so I don't know if
that's true but that's two people saying
that and so Troy Nails is going to Endor
Jim Jordan he was the one who saying he
was nominating Trump I bet Trump said
come on you know yeah man
we is why can't we have nice things it
was a fun Theory while it lasted Theory
it's a dream it is a dream it is a
vision I I'm you know how do we how do
we do we have to pray like who do we
contact who runs reality because we got
a spirit cook Tim we got to get abrina
abovich and we got to write messages to
Demons with our too bus working for
Ukraine you got you got to take enough
DMT to break the veil and then meet the
machine elves and ask them if they can
influence this to make Donald Trump
speaker okay fine I'm satisfied with
President Trump in 2020 2025 so we we'll
take it we'll take
it all right all right beagle cake says
excited for the event watching the show
while I wait for boarding right now
can't wait to meet you guys you guys are
a big inspiration it's going to be a
wild night and uh I hope everybody
understands we're doing the elite
members meet up at 3 p.m. which I think
is going to be around 50 or so people
will be at this this very private Elite
members only event and we're going to
eat it's going to be a lot of fun and uh
uh there's going to be a lot of great
people there we maybe even some of our
our guests I'm not entirely sure who
will who's who's planning on showing up
but I think we've got like we probably
have like 35 guests you know like
Friends of the show and prominent
individuals you're fans of who are going
to be there it's going to be amazing and
uh there's it's it's it's nearly a
thousand person theater so for everybody
who's attending definitely I'm going to
try my best to shake as many hands and
meet as many people as possible but you
know sad reality of life is I don't know
how much you know 10 seconds for you but
like 3 hours for me so I'll do my best
I'm really excited and really grateful
that y'all are coming and then of course
we got everybody else who's going to be
there too so it's going to be really I'm
really excited because I'm pretty sure
y'all are going to meet Alex Stein
because I'm I'm fairly certain Alex
Stein will run out into the crowd and
and yell and Shake everyone's hands and
and film it and it will be amazing and
I'm I'm really excited yeah he's going
to be doing standup right before and
then introduce all of us it's going to
be amazing Jason Dixon says Tim can you
please shout out the Discord again thank
you for everything that's right when
you're a member you can download Discord
which is a it's like a chat room you
hang out you become as a member you get
access to the timcast Discord you can
submit questions call into our
uncensored show but also there's tons of
people hosting their own conversations
their own shows working on projects
making music building culture it's
really really awesome so you guys should
definitely check that out because after
we wrap the uncensored show they keep
the show going with their own
conversation it's amazing here we go Bo
says we just had our local elections
here in Fairbanks Alaska I spent days
trying to get the vote out but we ended
up losing 6 to9 seats we're a really
conservative City but people just get
too complacent in off-ear elections that
is true that's why I think 2024 is going
to be very strange I don't know that
Republicans sweeping win everything the
polls are looking good for Republicans
but look a lot of people don't care a
lot of people like Trump and when they
vote for Trump they vote for everybody
else that's why repu like in 2018 we saw
this Trump brought the energy
Republicans didn't have it if Trump's
not on the ticket everybody else hurts
for
it Raymond g to Stanley Jr once again
says I don't know Tim first scripted
with poo and the continued excellent
timing of guests the last couple of
years did timcast news Shadow write the
Newsweek article you know it is really
funny that um every so often like we
book we book a guest who is the perfect
guest for like a news story it' be
really weird you know like uh for
example we planned this event a long
time ago we asked Matt Gates if he'd
want to be here it's in Florida and he
says yes and now he's probably the most
important politician in the country talk
to right now and like 3 Days Later he's
going to be on stage with us and I'm
just like thank you Matt gates for the
work you're doing in DC and coming to
our event this is going to be incredible
I almost couldn't believe it I'm like
dude he's it's what some's going to
happen you know what I mean like and and
the funny thing is he's actually trying
to stay in DC to get the job done and
they called a recess and he complained
he's like no we should stay here and we
should vote and I'm like no don't come
down like no he should he should
definitely do the work but I'm really
excited that we're gonna have a Matt
down here mat brings a fire man he he's
great speaker and the people love him
like there's you know I'm around TP
politicians but there's a few that
actually just energize a crowd and
connect with an audience Trump's
obviously one of that Matt Gates is cut
from that same cloth he's a fighter and
and that's the secret see everyone keeps
saying Matt gates for governor and
they're like no it's not true and
they're saying maybe he wants to run for
Senate no he's VP I mean like
likeability Gates likeability is
important and you're seeing that with a
lot of the 2024 Prim Challengers of
trump they're just not likable and when
you're against this most charismatic
likable guy you know it's you can't comp
wonder is there a possibility of I I I I
I I guarantee that if if Matt Gates were
here and I said do you want to be VP say
absolutely not I am fighting for you
know to make these changes in Congress
but I wonder about the possibilities of
trump asking Matt well you for
constitutional purposes you know there's
rhinos that are threatening to expel
Matt Gates right so if you expel Matt
Gates and Matt moves to Arizona and then
and then Trump picks him for
VP yeah I I mean honestly I do kind of
think like Matt would be the best choice
as of right now but it's obvious because
he's got all this energy behind him can
they be from the same state yes okay
it's a misconception well it's argued
but I'm pretty sure everything we've
pulled up has said you you can be from
the same state and there's something
else pertaining to it I don't know just
not when you get sworn in I believe is
that what it is yeah there restrictions
about like if you're actively in office
yeah when you run and both office for M
I don't know maybe Michael says Biden
Harris get reelected if Trump is Speaker
Biden Harris get impeached Trump is now
president God that would be so amazing
know this is a missed opportunity that's
a way to it to the White House yeah you
know what bothers me is that whoever is
writing the simulation is keeping it
boring it's like dude come on the people
want to be entertained you know we're
here you know we're living we want
entertainment we want speaker Trump but
what if Jim Jordan gave Trump an office
in the speakers no not the same no yeah
it would be funny though if Patrick M
Henry was like that that office who just
vacated pelis were're giving to Trump
because then then then it just shows he
only did it to to insult Nancy Pelosi I
well I I think that office is for this
if there's a speaker of the house that
remains in office like it's like it's
for like this the proceed yeah the
former speaker they get to office so now
McCarthy is the former speaker so he
gets it office so is that why he did it
yeah so it wasn't McKenry being like
look look at McKenry man he small man
where's a bow tie the guy doesn't got
swag he was just following procedure but
that gavl hit though you see how hard he
smack
thing he checked the thing after to make
sure it was still together amazing where
are we at let's grab some more Super
chats The Exodus conservatives say
allegedly Trump can't be uh can't can't
because he's currently under indictment
and there is a rule that says you can't
be speaker and be under indictment
Source Brian Tyler Cohen couldn't find
the rule can you fact check there is a
rule is my understanding but it's a it's
a republican rule it's not it's not a
law it's literally like the dress code
they were like okay fedman you can wear
shorts and then they were like actually
we changed your mind no shorts again so
they could literally just be like uh
okay Trump can you don't need it doesn't
indictment doesn't matter you're a
speaker there you go have you seen John
fed's Twitter game recently no whoever
he gave his Twitter passcode to probably
deserves a raise oh they're doing good a
lot of viral tweets a lot of viral
tweets a lot of good trolling on there
so game recognizes game and and
uh it's it's a PR marketing organization
with a whole bunch of uh you know it's
the guy used to run Wendy's
100% what do we got here Matt H says the
person I Lear uh I heard this from was
either Anne Colter or the Crowder guest
today pretty sure it was the Crowder
guest uh what is Matt referring to is
there a different Super Chat was that
the one uh I don't know what you're
referring to oh there you go I've heard
someone was being IND yes right about
the indictment right yeah so there was
articles about that but but they all
basically say Republicans get change the
rule it's like it's
meaningless radioactive rat says if I
want the goodie bag but I'm unable to
attend the event could I purchase the
ticket and pay for shipping to have it
shipped to
me well technically yes I guess the
issue is I don't know how we would do it
you know so or you can go on public
square.com
find other businesses and goodies that
you want from public square.com how hard
would it be to like make the bags and
list them on Public Square not hard at
all in in fact uh yeah let's talk after
this but if you want a goodie bag from
the event tomorrow email us at support
ATU sq.com you're going to make you're
going to have a lot of emails why not
just make something on your store on the
front page saying this the Good bag
we're going to sell so let's just do
that that's a great idea that way
anybody can actually get it all right so
after tomorrow night check go to the
Public Square app or go to public sq.com
we'll have on the featured page
basically the timcast special and it'll
have some of our favorites from tomorrow
nights and we'll put some we couple in
there too let's go we these are special
order bags and stuff which means we'll
we if if people are buying them we'll
order them and this is this is great
it's a sample pack of all these
different companies there's like jerky
in there there's coffee there's a bunch
of stuff this would be fantastic love it
all right check Public Square tomorrow
anytime probably after give us to like 3
p.m. and we'll put up a featured tile
and highlight the Tim cast special yeah
and you don't have to buy a ticket to an
event you're not going to you just enjoy
the products that's exactly right that'd
be fantastic right on all right we'll
grab some more Super chats Drew
outstanding field says Michael could
Public Square ever have a startup
business toolkit feature Basics to help
launch a venture CPA's lawyers marketing
videographers editors sales Etc in one
spot might help entrepreneurs launch
faster so this is an amazing question we
actually today soft launched a tool
called psq link so if you go to psq
link.com it's a business management tool
that's going to compete against
Salesforce for small businesses so that
you can grow your business super excited
Salesforce by the way Mark benof called
himself the most anti-conservative CEO
in the country canel project Veritas
when they were under James O'Keefe uh he
has lambasted any conservative cause he
actually funded the uh one of the
lawsuits into Trump yep which was insane
so that's who runs Salesforce it's a
total corrupt organization my my thing
about these guys is I understand you
like stepping in feces and living in
cities of squalor and disgust but the
rest of us don't so don't make it bad
for the rest of us hey we're not coming
to San Francisco and cleaning up your
poop we know you like it so don't come
to our places and bring poop ex you know
what I'm saying yep head to psq link.com
check out the tool it's pretty exciting
and uh you know a lot of by the way like
gun companies ammo companies are not
allowed to work with people like
Salesforce uh they make it really hard
on them and uh you know it depends on
your industry but a lot of times these
CRM tools won't touch you so we've
created a CRM tool that would love to
serve America small business Community
the other thing I will say is that
something that is actively in the works
at Public Square share your feedback
with us on if you would actually find
this valuable at support ATU sq.com
we're thinking about doing a Public
Square Shark Tank where we actually have
a lot of prominent investors from the
parallel economy he pitches from
America's parallel economy businesses
that are looking access to Capital we
had talked about this on the show let's
do it about how uh so we we we we've
been planning this thing where we
basically will just give someone a gift
of 10 grand every month we're trying to
figure out how to do it I know we we so
I'll just put it this way there has been
some stuff where I've given out money
but it's just private because then it's
it's a legal gift the challenge is if
we're giving away money there's a lot of
laws and regulations kind of jammed us
up and so some people had the idea of
like why don't you do like a a shark
tank style thing where you give seed
money to help people launch their
projects you guys doing it would be
amazing and uh well do we have an
investor what's up yeah let go you got
to be on the panel then that's looking
at inves in the
absolutely I will tell you I mean I got
to be honest I just I'm going to bang
the gabble for
everybody I'm going to be like I mean
look you know if you need $200,000 start
a business I'm going to be like yeah I
can't do that but if it's just like you
know
$10,000 and there depending on how many
people are there you know 10 people or
whatever I'm just like I don't care like
man we got to see this stuff we it's a
shotgun blast into seed projects if we
were able to fund as many people as
possible with with with with money to
start a business to start music to start
culture to make cartoons to make shows
to make cookies to make whatever what
happens is some people make it some
people don't it's sad reality but then
we have more seeds being planted as many
as possible so that was the general idea
it's it's been rather hard for us but we
have been doing um up until we start
doing promo for the event is that
Fridays instead of reading an ad we
shout out one of our members oh cool so
they're companies and stuff like that so
yeah we've had a lot of great a lot of
great members run companies uh one of
our designers just texted me and said so
I just got assigned work via YouTube for
the featured page tomorrow for the
timcast uh so we we've got our our
product designer Katie watching and uh
she's already on it building out the
timcast uh goodie bag for tomorrow on
the site so go to sq.com I like the
shark take idea I'd be happy to be an
investor as well so that' be amazing I
think we could have some fun I talk to
Founders all the time they said hey seoa
capital's not calling me like the
venture capital is not calling me
private Equity is not calling me they
don't like my values I don't have an ESG
score and they want access to solid
investors that are values in line with
them and then I also hear on the other
side these investors that are tired of
ESG dominated meritocracy ridden uh
investment opportunities they actually
want businesses that will focus on
quality products excellence service
providing value in an honest way not
worried about woke politics and so given
that we have the supply on the both
sides it would be really fun to put on
this production I think Luke would be a
funny investor I'm in CU they'd be like
you know we're no seed oil beef liver no
seed oils beef liver I'm in you know so
like what's going to happen is there's
going to be some little old lady and she
like I make cakes and then he's going to
be like is there beef liver in them no
put beef liver in them and then you got
a deal you got a
deal yeah seriously that Grandma marri's
beef liver cakes and then it becomes
like a multi-million dollar business
yeah I mean they have beef liver they
had beef liver uh smoothies at Aran that
were incredible but they just stopped
running them they were really good they
were actually really good um and they
don't have them anymore uh be liver
shakes and it tasted like
blueberries I don't like Li it tasted so
good I don't like Li you don't have to
there's there's different ways you could
consume it without actually tasting it
so uh but it is very good for your
health all right we'll grab some more
Super chats rabert G stanberg JR says I
feel like TDS on both sides of the aisle
would keep him from the speaker uh the
speaker the speaker phone but if he did
his campaign would run on getting it
done getting is done
yeah we got Ryan gisf says why stop with
Joe Biden how many other government
agencies could he go after and start
impeachment investigations for let the
Revenge start now Trump for speaker man
yeah think I think he might be better
off as Speaker getting revenge than he
would be uh uh in in in the white house
depending you know because and and and
that's why a temporary prision makes so
much sense he's he basically just says
I'm bringing to the floor all the bills
that are going to go investigate the FBI
special counsel investigation to Hillary
Clinton etc etc etc well if you have a
speaker like Jim Jordan that is willing
and able to work with a president Trump
in 2025 then you're going to have
tremendous success I mean when he was
president he had Paul Ryan for the first
two years and then Nancy Pelosi so we
didn't really have a friendly speaker at
any point and so if Jim Jordan is
successful in getting the speakers he's
getting the speakership then he will
have true ability to get retribution
from Congress as as well as the Oval
Office right on we'll grab some more we
got ranan thel I just added my business
to Public Square I make handmade glass
art and my business name is ethereal AVS
art and Tim I make glass chickens buck
buck that's fantastic let's go yeah I
think the map is the is the most
powerful thing yeah it's fun cuz it's
cool too because people get to check in
every few days every few weeks and just
watch more and more pins expand on their
it was crazy for us to just like pull it
up and be like oh look at this let's go
check that out like we're bored you know
what I mean that's the crazy thing is uh
uh we're looking for things to do and
it's like what have we not we've done
everything here and so we we're
traveling in greater greater distances
outside of our area we pull up the app
and we're like oh there a barbecue place
nearby and they're on Public Square
let's go we we went there and we got
food uh someone others others have asked
if you have um services like oh yeah
Carpenters electricians Lawn Care all
stuff that's that's huge because for us
especially with all the work we're doing
we're constantly trying to find
contractors of you know varying types
you just P the the Public Square app and
you can you know you're getting someone
good you also somebody like you you also
want to trust who's coming into your
home yep you know I was talking to
Marjorie Taylor green actually about
this she was like I have a hard time
when I travel country I don't know where
I can be comfortable having a meal and
so it's like pull up Public Square and
she's like that's what she does now Y
and so it's a place that people that are
a little bit more notable to feel safe
as well you know you know what you know
what does not feel safe is when you see
a business flying one of those cult
Flags yeah and with the creepy symbols
on it and I'm like the problem is these
people have advocated for extreme
violence against anyone who doesn't
align with them whether you're actually
far right or not and then these people
complain about American flags you
download the Public Square Marjorie
Taylor green when she goes to a
restaurant now they probably give her a
high five absolutely you know now she
knows she not only are is she going to
is she not going to get spit her food
they're actually going to make it better
they're going to be like we're going to
give her the good food well this
happened earlier this year when y'all
went to dinner it was Don JR njel farage
this whole incredible table like 20
people right for Kimberly's birthday
Gates was there yeah Matt Gates was
there and da mail actually wrote an
article about it because they went to a
restaurant on Public Square and the
owner loved them and invited him in and
all this stuff and it's like where else
could you have that crowd be welcomed in
a restaurant like that it was pretty
cool the owner was telling Don that the
first time he I met his dad was like in
1996 when he came to testify for like a
real estate uh hearing before Congress
and so um you know for for people like
that it's a really it's really important
for them and um you know I think the
contractors like I'm down in Palm Beach
West Palm Beach and pull up my phone
there's orthodontist there's you know uh
plumber there's electricians there's
every industry you can think of uh all
on the app that you can use and so um
it's been an awesome feature and I agree
with the map I look every couple days
new businesses new businesses new
businesses and it's an exciting Movement
we just moved to West Palm Beach like a
month ago from San Diego and uh we have
an 11-month-old daughter and I'm you
know just cautious of the medical system
um I know there are still some you know
really great people in that system but
the last few years have just really
burned I think a lot of us and so I'm
looking for a pediatrician that we can
trust so we go on the App we find our
new pediatrician she makes house calls
she's a licensed MD who left to create
her own natural and holistic practice
she starts there she focuses on
preventative health I mean it's just
amazing stuff and uh to have that
interaction I fully trust her to come
into our house and take care of our
daughter it's like I wouldn't find that
anywhere else the other exciting thing
is in the next 30 days look out for
November 1 we are launching fully
integrated e-commerce so the ability to
transact right there on the app one shop
multiple vendors we're also removing the
account wall so you no longer have to
sign in or log to browse that's really
exciting fully revamped desktop
experience whole new search November 1's
going to be really exciting so stay
tuned at public.com we'll just start
ordering all of our snacks directly
through the One-Stop shop of Public
Square we Anthem snacks right didn't you
order some Anthem snacks last they're
gone love it they're gone you ordered a
lot of beef jerky we did and it's all
gone and I was like the past couple
weeks I'm like where's the jerky and
like I go I go down to the store room
and I'm like am I not seeing it like
annihilated is the jerky LC approved I
haven't checked it I think it's clean
right it I I haven't had it yet and you
got carnivore snacks that's literally
just meat carnivore snacks is good it is
a Luke's got carnivore snacks The Anthem
stuff has brown sugar in it but the
ingredients are good so Luke may not be
a big fan of the sugar I'm not as big a
fan of the sugar but Anthem also has a
sugar-free it's like salt pepper jerky
legit yeah super good let's go shout out
yeah and then there's also um who is the
um uh uh uh man I'm forgetting what was
that jerky that we had that we just
annihilated the whole bag um I feel bad
I forgot the name of their jerky that
americanmade one I forgot it's called I
know you're talking about that's like
bra no it's not brave it's an a though
alpha or something like that was it
Alpha jerky I think it was aler Al jerky
I'm pretty sure it's Alpha jerky yeah
almost POS is that what it is they got
to get in Public Square for not already
and then you'll have like 27 different
jerky companies L beef jerky companies I
love it I mean d we like beef jerky you
know what I mean yeah I think it was
Alpha jerky wasn't it is yeah my
braining Jer I'm pulling it up yeah I'm
pretty sure that's that's it yep wait is
it I think so I'll use the moment right
now to say yeah sorry I was wrong about
the strawberry flavor it's actually
vanilla with the beaver butt thing
whatever anyways Alpha jerky Alpha jerky
it was Alpha jerky yeah I'm pretty sure
it's Alpha jerky I'm almost almost
postive I don't know I don't know man I
don't know it's an a something though
yeah Alpha jerky yeah they're on on the
yeah quality handmade beef jerky oh per
10 flavors to choose from there you go
there you go good stuff all right we'll
grab uh we'll grab a couple more uh
super chats right here yeah we had a bag
of it we just ate the whole thing like a
day all right
Jason ring says I'm currently being
audited by the IRS for making a movie
about the Q Shaman for
real dude these people are evil man
crazy Kurt green says the 13 colonies
only 3% fought the British and formed
our Constitution and the Second
Amendment for the very reason of what we
are going through now what is your
opinion of a possible Civil War well I
opinion when they're when they're going
after Elon when they're going after
Trump's properties and they're lying and
trying to seize his properties and
auction them off I mean this stuff's
insane or or it's speculated they would
do that yeah this is this this is this
is getting hot fast when with with this
the the the fraud lawsuit in New York
where they're saying Trump's properties
are not actually worth what they're
worth and he's they're going to try and
seize his property I mean this is
getting nuts they're arresting
lawyers but I will add it wasn't 3% that
fought in the uh American Revolution I
forgot we we we we we read through this
because that's a common talking point
there is something about 3% but um I
think
I forgot what it was it was it was a
large it was it was a huge percentage of
fighting age males that were fighting
but well 30% of the population was for
it well that's that was actually a
talking point so that was I think it was
who was it John Adams there's a or I
don't know someone had a famous letter
where they said a third's forward a
third's against it and the third doesn't
care but that was actually a generality
it wasn't an actual like statement of
fact it was basically just him saying
like look you know you've got people who
want it people who don't people don't
care Loy but it was actually something
like I think low 40s that were in favor
and then there was like mid 20s that
were opposed and then the rest just did
not care but uh a lot of sentiment for
it all right all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
we hope you will be uh you guys who
haven't already got your tickets for
tomorrow's event get them now at
timcast.net in just a couple minutes so
make sure you click join us Michael do
you want to shout anything anything else
out we are stoked to support you excited
about tomorrow it's going to be an epic
event you can find out more about Public
Square at public sq.com so you can shop
with companies that do not hate you and
I'm really glad to be here one of the
most effective and Powerful uh uh
tactics and and strategies we've had in
the culture war is these bycott and
boycotts and a lot of people are always
saying like it's really hard to figure
out what to buy or not you go to the
grocery store publicare Square launches
it's like here's a list of things you
can buy to replace all your garbage
products with companies that actually
agree with you and then you're taking
money away from the bad people and
giving it to good people Mr browit I
want to shout out Mike Lindell for being
a patriot that's go and I want you to go
to mypillow.com
SLO Jack money too support Jack bobic a
great Patriot and Mike Lindell God bless
you are you on Twitter I am where can
people find you on Twitter Alex brtz or
at Bill Mitchell's Twitter account he
tweets at me every other day so so
they'll find it it's easier easier to
spell than brtz it's true you guys have
a great relationship I hear um but uh
don't call him an aging lesbian well you
know you guys are you know whatever
thank you guys so much for coming on
yeah thank you guys so much appropriate
this was a lot of fun uh my health store
is we are change. shop I'm on Public
Square I have products made sourced and
manufactured in America they help me
they might help you we are change. shop
and check out my podcast with Clint
Russell we had three huge episodes on
rumble.com WE are Chang we're going to
be doing more of them here in Miami
rumble.com wear changed thank you so
much for having me Serge yo uh yeah I'm
excited for this after show excited for
tomorrow uh let's just get to it we are
going to be heading over to timcast.net